this is jocko podcast number 334 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
we were sitting by a thick section of
reprod a logging term for young timber
when i heard the high-pitched bugle
of a male elk
the 15-foot tall trees shifted like the
parting of the seas and a massive bull
stepped out onto the logging road
i was leaning on my knees trying to look
invisible as the black horned 6x7 bull
bore holes through me with his eyes
he was in bow range and when i decided
that i should try to kill him
the thing i'd been practicing to do for
months i realized that it felt like my
arms were asleep and my heart was
beating out of my chest
i don't know if i can even pull this bow
back the bull stood there only 40 yards
away from me there was no question i
should be able to kill him i'd shot
thousands of arrows at this distance all
summer
i pulled back the bowstring and released
the arrow missed the bull
shot behind his butt that meant i was
about seven feet off my mark which was
ridiculous
[Music]
this was what i'd call [__] the bed
my first bow shot of my life at an
animal couldn't have been much worse
i didn't get another opportunity that
day but something was ignited inside me
i'd never had any real ambitions or
goals for myself
but something changed
now all i knew was i wanted to kill a
bull
so right after that first day hunting
debacle i became obsessed and hunted for
the next 18 days straight determined to
succeed
that's right 18 days straight
finally on september 13 1989
i killed my first bull
the first animal that ever died from one
of my arrows was a small young spike
bull
granted it wasn't anything like the
giant 6x7 i blew it on but it didn't
matter it was my first bow kill and my
first bull elk
truth is i didn't deserve a big bull yet
i hadn't paid my bow hunting dues
and size aside i didn't know many guys
who had even killed a bull with their
bow so my spike bowl accomplishment
still felt special
it was almost a three-week grind but it
was worth it
some people lived their whole lives
never finding their true passion
i was 20 years old when i first tasted
bow hunting success and that marked
the time i discovered my purpose
suddenly i had something in my life to
focus my energy on
i quit college and quit about everything
else just to be able to bow hump more
i'll never forget where this journey
began and how long it's taken to hammer
away at a dream
we all have to start somewhere
nobody is born great at bow hunting
the average success rate on hunting a
bull elk with a bow is about 10 percent
so that's one kill every 10 years or one
guy out of 10 who is going to have
success
that's never going to be good enough for
me never was never will be average sucks
nowadays i earn success on virtually
every hunt in every state every year
so i expect to be 100
when the average is 10
that said i didn't wake up one morning
great at bow hunting
i have worked for more than 30 years to
get where i am today
it's not talent
it's drive
it's not raw ability
it's endurance
[Music]
hunting is my passion and being
successful at it is what fuels me every
day
to get better than the day before
and that right there is an excerpt from
a book
which is called endure
how to work hard outlast
and keep hammering
and if you haven't figured it out yet
this is a book written by an individual
named cameron haynes
cameron haynes
is one of the most highly respected and
successful bow hunters in the world
in order to get there in order to
get to that level of
expertise and ability
he has lived a relentless life
of utmost discipline
and unmitigated focus
and i guess since he's got this book and
he's written some other books
that he's an author and i guess
since he trains hard
he's an endurance athlete and i know
that he represents brands and i know
that he's founded and runs businesses
but first and foremost
he's a bowhunter
one of the best in the world
and we are lucky enough to have him here
with us tonight to share some of his
experiences
and some of his lessons learned along
the way
and how they apply not only to bow
hunting
but to life cam
thanks for joining us man yeah it's a
it's an honor to be here thank you guys
that's uh
that first one huh that first shot was
uh
the first shot you took was a miss oh it
was terrible what do you know what you
did wrong
um
yeah i mean i just was wrapped up in the
moment adrenaline was going crazy uh you
know how it gets coarsened through your
veins and you it's kind of a new
experience and
so intense with that bull coming in and
the reprod spreading like i said i could
see the tree shaking as it came down and
i'm just like
holy [__] what is going on
and then that bull and i'd been watching
the bull because i was up there the
night before on friday night saturday
morning the season opened
so i've been watching from about
i don't know mile and a half away or a
mile so i knew the bull and i knew what
we were you know what the focus was and
it was a big bull and i knew all that
from afar but once
once it gets in this in the show time
so i think i just hammered that trigger
of my release and probably peaked you
know when i shot
and just missed
it was brutal it's rough
well
we'll get to some of the some of the
more of those experiences and um i'm
sure you'll i'm sure i'll share some of
my very limited experiences but uh
definitely can get kind of crazy out
there yeah oh that's why we love it
though that intensity yeah no uh
yeah we'll we'll get to those kind of
things
you know it's
i think the term i that you use with me
um
is it can be heartbreaking
and i was kind of surprised you know the
first time i went i went hunting i
thought that no no one told me that it
was like a 10 success rate i kind of
thought like hey you just go out there
and you know when you're used to
shooting
with a rifle like hey you know you shoot
at something
first of all you can shoot a lot further
away and second of all when you shoot it
it's easier to hit it where you want to
hit it
and
it has so much force in a bullet that
it's going to cause some massive damage
and
you know
[__] dies yeah
it's not so easy with with a bow and
arrow no
more variables and then
it kills by hemorrhage so a whole
different thing shock muscle bone get
broke apart with the with the gun
with archery it's hemorrhage so it's
where you hit that animal
um
well let's let's before we jump into
where you're at now let's go back uh a
little bit to the beginning and where
you came from and where you grew up
um
going to the book this book
uh
freaking awesome
it order it order it right now uh
we're going to cover a little bit about
of it today so many stories and there's
so much detail
it's just an awesome read
so let's go to the book a little bit and
talk about where you came from you say
here the biggest legend
around eugene origin or oregon when i
was a kid oh wait what's that what's the
stress on oregon how are you supposed to
say it oregon
how do how do how are you supposed to
not say it oregon there you go
i'm dating close on that one
or again all right the biggest legend
around eugene oregon when i was a kid
was long distance olympic runner steve
prefontaine
but for me it was my dad
bob haynes was superman in my eyes
in a town known as track town usa my dad
excelled at the sport he earned a full
ride scholarship at the university of
oregon in gymnastics and after flunking
out there earned a full ride at oregon
state for track where they wanted him to
pull pole vault and high jump
that's that's a freaking athlete
if you're gymnastics and track
yeah
he was uh he was a beast and he just
grew up that's all he did track you know
junior nationals i had to scrap books so
i'd like always just look at a scrapbook
and
headlines and all these things and just
a great great athlete
beast
uh
you say he and my mom fast forward a
little bit he my mom linda brown met at
south eugene
i never forgot something she told me
when i was five years old your dad legs
are so muscular they're as hard as this
wood table
she said she pointed out our oat coffee
table little comments like that made him
seem larger than life
we covered a book on this podcast
it's called wooden leg and it was about
it was about an indian
and
his his name was wooden leg and the
reason they called him that was because
he could just like go and just keep
going yeah
so got them genetics yeah i guess so
yeah
uh going a little bit more forward again
on may 30th 1975 steve prefontaine died
in an automobile accident
earlier that evening stephen won a 5 000
meter run at university of oregon's
hayward field he was only 24 years old
the place where he crashed on the
winding narrow skyline boulevard is now
known as pries rock
four years earlier another car accident
happened only 10 minutes from pries rock
nobody got killed but it might have
helped tear a family apart it's one of
my earliest memories of my parents when
they were still married in fact it's one
of my only memories i was four years old
and i woke up hearing my mother yelling
i went to find her standing by the door
heading into the garage talking loudly
and frantically to my dad
when i stepped to her side and followed
her eyes i noticed the side of my dad's
car was damaged as if he had just hit
another vehicle
i didn't know this at the time but my
dad was an alcoholic
thankfully bob haynes was able to walk
away from this accident not long after
that
my parents divorced
so that's what that's what was going on
when you
were that's like your earliest memories
or really you say your only memories of
your parents being married yeah and then
you know then they were divorced and i
would go back and forth so i but them
together that's about that's about it
one other night
my dad he once college was over he'd
play softball and
he came home one night i remember his he
must have slid in the base he had a
bunch of blood running down his knee and
i was i remember sitting there watching
tv and
looking at that so those two that's
about it
that night after the softball game with
blood and then when he was you know
drunk and hit a car
you go through in the book you know you
talk about the
uh you know your mom she's
well i mean she's gotta kind of carry on
with her life right i mean she starts
dating other guys uh eventually she gets
married
to
who ends up being your stepdad how old
were you when that happened
i think five
and what what did he do for work
he drove roller for the paving company
got it
sounds like he was a bit of a boozer too
yeah yep
definitely
definitely had drinking issues and then
you know he wasn't my dad so i hated him
i don't think he liked me
definitely didn't seem like it so yeah
it's
you know
whatever it happens that's just the way
it seems to go doesn't it sometimes with
the step dads
yeah that but
it's a hard it's a tough job for them
yeah they're coming in
they're
the woman better be pretty hot if
they're gonna have to deal with
freaking kids that's all i know and
there's two of you is there two of you
yeah yeah so it's you and your brother
right yeah my younger brother he's a
couple years younger
so yeah it's my mom my mom came with
some baggage yeah instant fan we used to
say in the seal teams like when a guy
would meet up with some girl or start
like seriously dating a girl and maybe
even get married to a girl that had a
couple it's like instant family yeah you
know you don't get any
like a normal normal
you get married you have like the
honeymoon period or whatever
two three years just you and this girl
but no you got instant family i know
what are you doing on saturday you're
freaking doing yard work and like
there's no honeymoon period no i know
it's rough rolling straight into it yeah
and then you got young cam who hates you
and
you know i have since my dad wasn't
around i i just had this vision of my
dad
and from what i heard in the scrapbooks
and so then this guy who comes in
what who the [__] are you what have you
done
drive roller
you know so it's a tough hand it's like
it's no win for sure for him
uh
you got some crazy stories in here i had
to pull this one out though i don't even
know why th this wood kind of struck me
because it seems like this kind of [__]
happens uh to to everyone in some way
shape or form you got this going on when
i was in third and fourth grades my mom
worked with and became friends with this
lady at the phone company i remember her
being very pretty and nice
they went out on weekends leaving pete
and me with the woman's teenage sons to
babysit my stepdad had a harley and so
did the husband of my mom's friend so
they would go out on road trips or maybe
just out for the night while it was a
long time ago i don't remember all the
details there are a few things i do
remember that might always haunt me the
teenage brothers weren't the greatest
babysitters they used drugs and made me
and my brother fight in front of their
friends they'd yell and scream and treat
it like entertainment coaching us on how
to hit each other hard
whenever there was blood the boys yelled
louder and got even more fired up pete
and i didn't like it but i don't
remember having a choice or maybe it was
the way for us young boys to try and
earn approval from the older boys
the brothers watched us at our house as
we had a pool table and they got then
they and their friends had something to
do as they acted crazy and got drunk and
high during those stressful nights they
made me smoke pot so i couldn't tell on
them how old were you third grade
damn
we do whatever they said so i smoked pot
and then they put shaving cream in my
mouth as they said it mask the scent of
pot
the younger brother did most of the
communicating with us and said if we
told on them they would tell my mom that
i smoked pot too
if i hadn't already learned that life
wasn't always going to be fun
and loving i did then
my young eyes were open to the fact that
there were people in this world that you
could never trust and that would hurt
you for entertainment
that's freaking crazy
and you go on to say that the one
brother
uh one of these two brothers ended up
dead of a heroin overdose
and the other one
tripped out on some kind of drugs and
killed one of his friends yeah he uh
took mushrooms
that not long after i mean during that
whole time and
um
thought his friend was the devil i think
is what it was and
ended up killing him
when he was 15.
damn
so this is uh
this is a rough scenario you're living
in right now
and how often are you getting to go to
your dads
uh
my dad was
you know he's having issues of his own
with drinking and you know he'd have
girlfriends and
um
i think he worked at a he was a
bartender at the black forest there's a
tavern there off of willamette and
eugene and
so yeah he's
you know he's young too
[__] you know you're 20 some years old
you don't want to have to
take care of some kid
so
so it's pretty much mostly most of the
times at this point is spent with your
mom yeah
um
you go through more stuff about that i'm
gonna fast forward a little bit to
middle school
middle school you're you're trying to
trying to make things happen even in
middle school you got a paper route
you're doing strawberry picking uh
you got you you put this quote in here
you said during this period of my life
with all the time to be in my own head
and that's when you're out picking
strawberries or you're out delivering
papers
one constant thought came to my mind
this sucks
that's pretty heavy
for a freaking middle school kid yeah
i remember because at that time the the
local paper was every day so i'd have to
get up at four
and in you know oregon especially
willamette valley there i mean it rains
a lot especially in the winter
dark as [__] four in the morning i'm out
there loading up my little canvas bag
you put papers on the front and back
it's kind of
uh strung over your shoulders and then i
just ride my bike to the houses and
deliver but i'd have to get that all
loaded up at the paper box they'd come
and drop the papers off like at two in
the morning
i'd go out there a four and get all that
and it's pouring down rain and i'm just
like
sucked
i mean it was it you know i know lots of
people have paper routes but
yeah given everything else and then at
that time i had moved in with my dad
because i hated my stepdad so much
so i was and i i didn't miss anybody but
my brother basically we'd kind of been
in it together
and so i'd lived with my dad my my step
or i mean my brother would stay with my
mom because he didn't really know my dad
that well because he's so young
and uh
and yeah so it was like giving
everything else and then that situation
yeah i felt like a lot
fast forward a little bit more you say
since my dad was some legendary track
guy i decided to attempt to follow in
his footsteps
during one particular track meet i was
excited to see my stepmom candy come and
watch me knowing that she was going to
tell my dad how i did he wasn't there
himself but his spirit loomed large like
it always did it was really hard to get
his attention in athletics since he was
gone traveling around with junior
national teams
you couldn't do regular [__] and be
celebrated i knew i had to make my mark
so i decided i would do it in the 800
meter race at that meet
when the gun went off
i took off as if it was a 200 meter dash
i ran like steve prefontaine going out
as hard going out hard and refusing to
let go of the lead
for a short while
a very short while i raced at the front
but by the end of the first lap i was
dying
i still remember the guy who won the
race
greg suter he was a natural track guy
who won all the time he looked like a
runner tall and lean i was the
short-legged kid gasping at the end of
the race and finishing last
i was thankful my dad hadn't accompanied
my stepmom to the meat
this was my normal i just didn't have it
that's what i grew up with
life has always been a grind
coming out of the gate hard
800 meters i heard somebody talking
about 800 meters
and they were saying like there's people
that run you know everything from a 5k
to a marathon like that's all that's all
uh what's the word sort of fun stuff
that people do but there's no one that
goes out like hey we're hey you guys
we're running an 800 this weekend
because it sucks so horribly yeah it's
the half mile basically a sprint
it's tough
especially when you're not you know i
just
was just a kid middle school kid wasn't
born to do it so is this like sixth
seventh grade what grade is this i think
that was probably
i'd say seventh or eighth
yeah
and you got your ass beat and did once
you want did you feel like you know i
mean this is the kind of thing that's
the kind of thing that sends kids like
just off of the other direction did you
feel any of that did you keep doing
track
uh no because then then my dad moved to
portland so i moved up there which is a
much bigger city than eugene
and uh then
i didn't even get a chance to compete at
anything because if i wasn't good at a
smaller school i'm not getting anything
so i remember up there right you were a
small fish in a small pond
when you got to the big pond you were
like a minnow oh my god it was not even
i was i might as well
i didn't exist
as far as the school goes yeah i mean
it's just like nobody knew me i never
made one friend
i mean it was i remember laughing guys
no you might [__] no maybe a little
bit it's it it's just i would be
laughing too
it's like i remember i had zits all on
my chin
um
you know i'm like god so i did mow lawns
i took
my dad lived in a pretty good area he
opened this record store in downtown
portland like collectible records that's
what he loved to do
and
so i would be out in beaverton which is
out of portland and i would go and mow
yards and get get some money that way
nobody's giving me money
and uh yeah i mean
my brother would come up i remember one
time he came up to visit and he didn't
didn't like going up there but we played
one-on-one football
i was better than him because i was two
years older so it was like that was my
that was a glory
to me that was glory
like reliving the one-on-one football
match with your little brother
uh you do end up doing your first hunt
with your stepdad what was it what was
that all about
that was uh they you know he grew up in
a real small town in eastern oregon echo
oregon
and
so they would
do this big deer camp so
it's a tradition every year they'd have
a deer camp where they'd have a wood
stove and and a big you know
outfitters tent
they'd play cards and drink and you know
that was that was rifle deer hunting
so like i say in the book you know i got
handed to my step-dad for even taking us
over there because i guarantee his
brothers which were just they're all
badasses pretty intimidating like ranch
guys
you know big rent they had a big ranch
outside of echo oregon
and uh
then we got these kids you know greg's
stepsons
they're probably like what what is this
you know how guys are they don't want
kids around right
and uh so
i did me and my brother were out
and i saw these deer coming up the hill
and i
thought i saw a spike horn
on one of them which made it legal so it
was because it was a buck had to be a
buck
and i shot it my my brother said you
shot a doe
and i'm like no i didn't i didn't know
for sure i was like pretty sure but i
was 100 sure after he said that i was
like oh my god
so how you know what's the biggest screw
up you could do is shoot some illegal
animal right
so anyway it turns out it was legal and
i got it and that was my first deer and
i was 15. and did you get like the the
rush did you did you enjoy that
uh
i don't remember that part i just
remember
maybe i finally did something good like
like get approval from from the man
so
uh
now
despite everything and i like i said
skipping through a bunch of the book
there's more detail in here but you
eventually say this it's easy to use
your childhood as a crutch
instead of seeing it as a chisel
there are a lot of divorces out there so
that means a lot of kids come from
broken homes i always hear people say my
family is so dysfunctional using it as
an excuse or something but is not really
a valid excuse because everybody's
family family is dysfunctional in some
way there are so many crutches people
want to use to justify themselves but
for me
you have to eliminate every single one
of them get rid of them all
then tell yourself it's up to you
what are you going to do now that you
let go of all those crutches i could
blame alcoholism on a shitty childhood
but i don't
blaming others is an easy way out
solid advice
yeah you got to take ownership of what's
going on in your world stream ownership
that's a good call
it's a good idea yeah that's uh you know
i was just talking to some people this
past
past week
and i was saying isn't it crazy i i said
i wrote this book sold a lot of this
book
and what we wrote about in this book is
hey you should take responsibility for
your actions that's the main underlying
premise and isn't it shocking that
people almost treat that like a novel
idea yeah
but it's like wait let me jot this down
say that again
and and the thing that i was also
explaining this group of people that
said it's really heavy
when you start to look at your
you know you look at your life you look
at your health you look at your business
you look at your family you look at your
relationships and you look at all those
things that are messed up in all those
areas and when you say all those things
all those problems in my business my
life my health all those things are my
fault that's really a heavy weight to
bear
but it's also extremely liberating
because if it's all your fault you're
the one that can fix it yeah you're the
one that can get your business back
together you can repair the
relationships you can get yourself
healthy like you can take control of all
those things
and that's the exact same thing you're
saying here when you're just blaming
your childhood or your parents or your
alcohol the alcoholism all these other
things
then you just become a victim to those
things and that's not what can you
change you're just a victim
it's happening to you
and you need to go make things happen
yourself not let them happen to you
right uh definitely one of the
underlying themes in this book you put
out
fast forward a little bit to high school
which you started getting into as a
freshman entering a new high school i
had no confidence and zero success to
point to or build momentum off of life
got worse after i decided to live with
my dad when he moved to portland
suddenly i found myself in this big
school i didn't want to i didn't want to
attend where i didn't know anybody i
struggled in my classes i earned mostly
ds as a freshman i ate like [__] and
wasn't active so i started gaining
weight and to make matters worse acne
became an issue
basically you're a teenager too in a way
it's just gonna happen yeah but there
was like some studs like i'd see this
i'd see the studs and like they didn't
seem like they had zits
and they didn't seem overweight or and
looking down at the floor as they walked
by everybody so wasn't everybody
[Music]
that's uh that's a rough one yeah um
you said this though uh fast forward a
little bit soon i realized things had to
change
that the situation in portland was dire
feeling alone and isolated caused me not
to give any effort in school or make
friends my grades were all d's i was
overweight and insecure so i moved back
with my mom for my sophomore junior and
senior years i knew it hurt my dad but i
was miserable and felt desperate
i then attended mohawk high school in
what is it marcola yep in marcola it was
a small school in a small town marcolo
was a logging community with a lot of
guys working out the woods i loved
growing up in a small town but like many
others from humbling humble beginnings i
carried low expectations and no dreams
i wasn't looking down the road the
change of schools didn't help me because
even though i never did my homework and
i wasn't considered smart i also wasn't
dumb
i began to get good grades i ended up
getting straight a's when i was a senior
that's a freaking dramatic change
i got so lucky because i joined the
military and i just got like put on a
path this is what you got to do yeah
now that structure is important freaking
so good
uh
now you end up playing football
and do you think that impacted sort of
you start playing football you start
having some structure and discipline
around that does that help your grades
are you wanting to get good grades just
to play football or anything like that
yeah
i mean
i don't know i just had a little i felt
a
smaller school maybe is back in the
small pond again so i felt
more confidence and then
um
playing you know building a bond with
people like the other guys on the team
and on our my road we lived on wind lane
road so there's a bunch of good athletes
that live there so we'd get together and
play basketball or football
and so
just that just competing i think
i think competition
is what
is what life
i mean that's kind of a mistake i i felt
for a long time i made with raising my
own kids is i learned right there that
life is competition
and competition is what made me
like hey i got i have to
go one-on-one with we just do these
drills like football one-on-one you try
to get over this line they try to get
over this line it's just whoever can you
stop him or he can can he stop you so i
realized those those battles that's what
makes especially a man is like we got to
compete that's what we're here for so
when i
i kind of skipped ahead but um with my
kids i like no you guys
life is going to break you
if you're not built for this [__] so
then i thought well maybe did i push
them too hard to compete so it's like
you know how life is you're like one all
one way or all the other but anyway i
was learning how to compete there and
and it gave me confidence
and
you start running then too
and and you had a buddy donnie manilla
yeah and you guys are sort of sort of
sort of best friends scenario and he's
he's a quarterback yep
and you're his wide receiver yep so you
guys are bros out freaking oh yeah
practice it everybody get in shape and
getting after it yeah uh
you you talk about the fact that you're
you kind of had to be self-sufficient i
mean this whole time which is definitely
good yeah um yeah it was tough at that
time but it's good for any
any person eventually you're gonna have
to you know take care of yourself
yeah you know going back to that
competition thing i know in the seal
teams we always joke around like if
you're with another seal whatever you're
doing
is a race
whether you're and sometimes it can get
pretty stupid because sure it's cool
when you're running or it's cool when
you're shooting but then it's like hey
we're going to go drink yeah
let's say you can do better you know
yeah
not as great to win that one
yeah not not a great one
uh
you also end up going to your grandma's
house
which seems like i'm like oh that's
that's quaint but it's a 20 mile bike
ride you got it yeah so it's a 40 mile
round trip
and what are you doing up there
uh she lived in town so she lived by
hayward field i lived in the outskirts
on this in that small town so i would
ride there on this old two-lane road all
the way into town and then i would hang
out watch mtv
go up to eldon's market she had a tab up
there so i'd go buy stuff
go down to amazon pool just kind of play
basketball hang out but that was like my
i could get away from my stepdad
my dad could swing by because it was his
mom so i couldn't see my dad maybe he
still lived in town but
um i don't know what he's doing
and so it's kind of a you know she'd
give me made saltine crackers with
butter on them it's a pretty good life
living the dream and then what your
other your other
i guess maybe your mom's side had a
ranch they had a ranch in eastern oregon
and you went out worked on that yeah
yeah
i did my uh grandpa was a horse trainer
and super tough he's you know
i he uh left home i think he lied to get
in the service when he was 15 or 16.
and uh one you know
was in the military just tough
tough dude
and uh he got into horses he did uh
rodeo when he got out of the service and
then started training and and breeding
horses so i'd go over there and work and
he had
he was
tough tough guy
did you ever do rodeo no
when i when i watch that
like
i don't like to get injured right you
know i mean none of us like to get
injured when you get injured you know
you feel like it's horrible and you feel
like the whole world's falling apart and
i feel like the biggest wimp when i get
injured because i'm always like okay
like my
i've jammed my finger and my grips now
you feel like just like and then you
know guys that you know have lost legs
and they're driving on
uh but man when i watch
rodeo people how how are they not
getting
majorly injured every freaking time
they're durable
damn
yeah that and i watch you ever watch
rugby yeah those guys are tough too i
watched a rugby game like a year ago and
same thing every play
i was shuddering and you know so you
know a lot of times you get that feeling
when you watch a sport you're like i
could do that yeah you know you're like
oh yeah i'll do that i could if i
trained hard i could get in there you
know you're
but i was watching this rugby game going
i actually don't want to do that
i actually do not want to do that these
guys are impact every single time
so you're out there are you and this is
like typical ranch stuff where you're
learning the like extra hard work is
getting after it yeah yeah just get up
early get all the horses fed and watered
um i would
because he had racehorses so he bred
quarter horses and i would i would go
and um
warm them up before the races so it's
called a jockey boy and so i'd get on
there and to do that i had to know
horses the a horse can tell whether you
know the person on them knows what the
[__] they're doing especially
horses that are all wound up for the
races
it's a it's pretty that was pretty
intense but i like doing it how long did
it take you to get
comfortable on the horses was that like
your introduction to it that that summer
no i i'd i would ride every time i went
there okay yeah so you kind of grew up
doing it yeah and then when i worked for
him
he uh i'm trying to thank i think he
paid me
seems like it was a hundred and for some
reason 76 a month
but then i had to pay for all my own
stuff
so like food and water and yeah and like
i remember he took me to uh
to buy clothes like jeans and a and a
cowboy hat and things like this and that
came out of 176.
i thought he was hooking me up but
no grandpa bob's got a different way of
him no no he was
yeah
uh
so you learn a lot from him and and i'm
gonna fast forward a little bit you say
i learned something else from grandpa
bob i was taught that tomorrow is not
guaranteed
my mom's mother drove her car over from
their ranch in eastern oregon to visit
to visit and go to my homecoming
football game on friday late thursday
night the sheriff's department called
and told us that papa had died in an
automobile accident
it was very painful to hear this since
grandpa bob was a huge part of my
teenage years
the following night the homecoming game
was tough to get through but i had a
good game and made some difficult cat
catches papa taught me to give
everything you have each day
and the only thing that mattered was
winning
when a horse wins the trainer the jockey
and the family get to take a photo in
the winner's circle
anything less than that
is a failure
check
that was was that your senior year then
that was junior junior year junior year
yeah
um
fast forward a little bit you graduated
earlier you graduated when you were 17
years old
and and then you get a job at safeway
yeah i
kind of forgot this part of the book but
my it was weird my family moved when i
was 17. so they they were gonna go to
arizona
and uh
i just said i'm not going to arizona and
so i stayed and they moved
they only stayed there two weeks but
they they moved back but i never moved
back home what'd you get like a place to
stay with your buddies or something no i
stayed with my girlfriend so she was a
senior too so we were it's kind of kind
of sounds odd i mean right now if i
imagine my daughter
like us moving my daughter's a senior
i couldn't imagine just hey
good luck keep in touch yeah and by the
way move in with some other high school
senior i know
anyway so i stayed they moved back i
never moved back in and then i ended up
getting a job at safeway because i
wanted to wait my
manila oh no he was a year behind me so
i wanted i needed we're going to go to
try to play college football together so
i worked for a year in between waiting
and and then you end up getting to
southern oregon state
and you try out for the football team
you say after i try after trying to make
the team i redshirted for southern
oregon state meaning every day i
practiced against the starting defense
there were definitely some beasts out
there on the field i definitely wasn't
one of them
it was fun especially since there were
some elite athletes on the field who
eventually made it to the nfl the irony
of college was that throughout my high
school years i never drank even one beer
all i cared about was sports and grades
i knew i wasn't an elite athlete but i
still tried my hardest especially
because i wanted to impress my dad what
i learned at southern oregon was that
even though i wasn't good enough to play
college football
i knew how to party
i drank a lot of beer and eventually
went back to eugene with this new
mastered skill
so
so you didn't drink it all growing up no
and then you get to college
and it's just like the stereotypical
freaking
you could just go get it yeah i mean you
know how if you're on the football team
you can go to any party
you know always girls always you know we
had this dorm that was aspen hall was
just football players so
there's always girls there there's like
like a big open shower and there'd be
guys and girls in the shower it's the
same as like i'm like this
i don't know what heaven is like but it
feels
like it should be like this
so
anyway it was it was a lot different one
of my buddies in the seal teams played
football at university of texas and
obviously it's like a religion down
there and i was like hey what was it
like you know being on the football team
down there and he goes
jolly like a jolly green giant walk in
the earth
[Music]
he said you lit he said he literally
could do anything he wanted to yeah you
know you no one he never bought a beer
you know it was like the seas parted
when he showed up he said it was
freaking
ridiculous so how long did you stay
there for just a year so one year yeah
one year but yeah i mean so it wasn't
like texas but for that little that was
ashland oregon for that little town
yeah it's kind of a big deal if you were
there yeah yeah it's fun
and what made you stop what made you
decide to not go to college anymore i
just didn't have money so nobody's
paying i had financial aid and i was
getting money and so it was about 5 000
a year living down there and and i was a
walk-on so i didn't get any scholarship
or anything like that so i just didn't
have money
yeah did you have any vision
no
yeah because i think a lot of kids just
go to college because that's like you're
supposed to what you're what it is
yeah it's just like that's that's like
the normal chain of command is you you
got to get your college degree
you know so we tell i told my kids
tanner who's in the service he
he tried that's my oldest one but i i
went through first and you know told him
no you're going to go to school you're
going to get a degree and
i could tell
it's just not happening so
but anyway i fell into that trap too
yeah now you go to go to college yeah
especially
you go there for a year and you're like
what am i even doing here yeah you know
like getting drunk whatever spending
money why why am i even here yeah i got
decent grades i mean i i took creative
writing so it was like i always liked
writing so at least i did that
yeah that's an interesting thread that's
throughout the book is your and
obviously this book is sort of the apex
of that journey but
yeah the fact that you were always kind
of into writing
so you get you
leave college
um
go back going back home
and now you're working uh you're working
in a warehouse for 4.72 cents an hour
according to the book that's right
i was working part-time going to going
to lane community college
and uh you know my my truck little
toilet two-wheel drive was just full of
beer cans all the time because we just
go up in the woods and build a fire at
the rock pit and
drink and
that's what i mean i would go scout deer
i always like taking pictures
so i'd go look for bucks and bulls and
try to take pictures of them in the
mornings but then i would you know drink
for the weekends in the afternoons
yeah he's saying here it wasn't like i
was letting anybody down
no nobody expected anything from cameron
haynes so i didn't expect anything out
of myself
no
fast forward a little bit
thankfully
roy kept on me and kept encouraging
encouraging me to bow hunt telling me
it's way better than hunting with a gun
that there were less people
and that i would enjoy it
roy got me started but the only way i
could build confidence in anything was
to go out and do it soon i focused my
energy on bow hunting like athletics it
provided a challenge
i found the perfect thing to work hard
at something that challenged me that not
everybody was good at when i was
successful at bow hunting it gave me a
lot of confidence for a young man having
confidence and getting positive
reinforcement in anything was a powerful
spark
for change in my life here's the truth
i'm an average guy who has experienced
above average bow hunting success over
the past three decades one thing is for
sure if i can do it anyone can i came
from nothing and had no one pushing me
or even believing in me for this reason
my story proves that in bow hunting the
most average person can achieve the
grandest of dreams
footnote there's a lot of a hell of a
lot of hard work in between average
person and dreams on that one so how did
you know roy roy roth he went to mohawk
he was a year ahead of me
so he was uh and then his wife was in my
class she was like the brain of the
of the class i think she could have got
valedictorian maybe um so that was jill
but yeah so we but we didn't hang out
because he
i just did the
football basketball baseball
he had a trap line and would always be
in the woods trapping he did play foot
he was good at football and baseball but
no basketball but we didn't really hang
out or anything but he he was always the
guy if i had a hunting question i'd be
like well i'm just gonna ask roy he's
like the best in school
and
so
he
from there we kind of built a
relationship when i was still rifle
hunting and then he inspired me to buy a
bow and
and uh get going down that road
you say i run into a lot of people who
are new to bow hunting they get a bow
going on a hunt and they discover it's
just too difficult so they quit i
understand
i missed 16 deer the first year i went
bow hunting so i've been there what if i
had given up after the first year
there's the question once again what if
here's the reason why bow hunting is
both exciting and excruciating
it's difficult and frustrating as hell
especially when you're used to hunting
with a rifle people become used to the
ritual of seeing an animal in rifle
range and then boom it's over
it's done you've made the shot the
animal is dead with a bow being in bow
range doesn't mean anything even if the
animal is in rifle range when you're bow
hunting the hunt has just started moving
from rifle range into bow range means
you're moving into the animal's red zone
and that ups the challenge immensely in
bow hunting there's no guarantee it's
going to work out
for me i never liked to fail i didn't
want to be a failure with the bow so
after that first year of killing the
spike bull elk my second season behind
the bow i killed a pope and young 3x3
blacktail a raghorn 5x5 bull and a bear
with a two hundred dollar bow and using
thirty dollar binoculars
i could only afford to hunt in oregon
instead of traveling anywhere out of the
state
i bought three tags and filled three
tags
the second year bow hunting wasn't just
memorable for me it was monumental
you came out of the gate
going hard yeah yeah i mean that was i
finally found because
as you you know we've kind of went
through this journey i wasn't good
really
not like a natural at anything it's all
work and then i got to bow hunting and
i'm like well
i can work hard and then have these
what i considered a very you know pretty
high above average um
maybe
excellent results and i didn't know
anybody killing a bull buck and bear
with their bow that was like there's
like a we'd lump those all together in
one word bull buck bear and if you could
get that done with your bow
that's freaking badass yeah it wasn't
happening so i felt really good that was
just my second season so it gave me a
lot of confidence
how many arrows were you shooting in the
off season getting ready for that were
you were you
kind of obsessed out of the gate yeah
yeah i shot way more than that i do now
yeah i mean i just shot for hours
yeah
loved it
um
how did you get the feel for
like the hunt part
the wind was roy teaching you that stuff
no that was just you know um
rifle hunting you don't really need to
know that but i was in the woods a lot
you know whether i was hunting or
um going with somebody
so i was learning you kind of hunting is
all about
well not all about there's a lot of
different things that you got to read
the country you got to read the anim the
animal behavior is a big part of it and
learning their tendencies and then what
you can get away with when they see you
and so i would as i said
you know i would go out and take
pictures a lot too so i was out trying
to get photos
and then hunting all the time so i just
was naturally just learning more all
these reps all this time in the in the
mountains
so then when it came time
for to actually try to kill something
i had a big advantage because i had just
been out there the time spent you know
and uh
it just it felt pretty natural but i
still had to learn about the wind
had to learn about when an arrow hits an
animal and you're reading the blood
trail where that blood's from the injury
you've caused the animal
you know how to trail that thing whether
it's hoof marks in soft soil
or
rocks overturned
different things
ferns would be
kind of indicate the direction of travel
so you had still had to look a lot of
woodsmanship go goes into successful bow
hunting so i had to learn that that just
takes time
were you going with anybody are we
primarily like that first year where you
got the bull buck and bear was was
anyone going with you
my brother went sometimes i think when i
killed that buck he was there too uh
um
and then the bull let me think no the
bull i was by myself a bear by myself
yeah yeah
i guess the reason i'm kind of pausing
here is like i said me being an amateur
hunter and having
been guided on hunts by experts
or sometimes even multiple sometimes i
i've gone out with both john dudley and
a guide with me at the same time so
there's like two people that are experts
right
and the amount of information that
they're feeding me
the amount the amount of things that are
going on during a hunt
is
there's so much going on yeah i mean the
reactions the animals the wind the
terrain
like all those things are going on
i've had i've when i've hunted i've had
people you know uh feeding me that
information you know
and for you to be out there on your
second season
pulling that off that's freaking
impressive man
and i don't want and
and the other reason why i'm kind of
like diving into this is because i said
oh how many arrows did you shoot
and
er shooting the arrows
yeah you got to be able to shoot the
arrows but there's so much more to it
yeah that i didn't want to make it sound
like oh hey if i shoot a bunch of arrows
and i can hit that target at freaking 60
yards i'm gonna be good to go
i think hunting
it's like when you're driving somewhere
and if you're not driving
not really paying attention you know
what i mean i feel like hunting can be
like that too if you're not making the
calls you can have people telling you
just like you can have somebody drive
you down here if somebody's i
like if i had to
repeat how i got to right here the
studio today
i took an uber so i don't know
but when you're hunting
when you're making the calls that
it might be a rough go you might fail a
lot but you're also learning more than i
think
you have some great mentors on the hunt
but i think um it's hard that's a hard
situation to learn that first-hand
experience also because you're kind of
you're doing what they say yeah you know
what i mean um
so for me it was
it was hard but it was a big advantage
to learn that on my own
make those mistakes on my own
and and it just
i think being by myself so much as a kid
i was fine being by myself i liked i was
used to being alone my whole life you
know really so just being out in the
woods that just that was an easy
transition now i'm i'm by myself but i'm
doing something
i'm not by myself you know
uh
you know staring at the wall eating
cheetos
yeah that's uh
again just to reiterate the the amount
that goes into pulling this off
is
is ridiculously hard these this is a
freaking challenging
challenging
thing to do so i just don't want to
don't want to short sell it at all
yeah it's i mean there's still hunts now
even after all these years where i'm
like
i wonder i'm like how have i ever killed
anything with an arrow
i mean it just seemed it feels
impossible on some of these hunts
because it's not just getting close yeah
i mean that's
you find the animal that's okay well now
we're now we've started something at
least we got a target right
but then
so much has to go right
and then if you're trying to film as you
know i think you've you know some of
yours has been filmed and other guys are
there so it's like there's however much
you know three guys that's three times
the noise three times a cent three times
the movement it's tough
it's there's a lot of [__] that can go
sideways yeah and it does and so again
what i was my point was sometimes i
wonder myself i'm like i don't know how
i've ever done this
it feels
feels like it's just
not going to happen
but
well you've made it happen a lot
get into your third season you say i was
invaded by invited by wayne endicott to
join him in the country he had hunted
since he was a young boy wayne owned the
bow rack
and i only say it like that because it's
kind of like legendary even though i've
never even been there yeah uh the
archery pro shop in springfield oregon
opened in 1971.
wayne roy roth
dwayne levitt yeah right
jeff brooks and i ventured toward the
legendary steens mountain
and
there
you say this my shot was perfect a 35
year a 35 yard cording away shot the
arrow went into the last rib and stopped
at the far side of the shoulder meaning
i only had one hole the entrance from
which to leave blood
i was using thunderhead 125s which are
good tough heads that did the job that
one perfect arrow put the bull down
quickly even though i had scant blood
trail to follow the roosevelt bull
was a big bodied beast though and his
heavy hoofs scarred the soft soil deeply
i followed his fresh deep cutting tracks
for 50 yards down the hill before
pulling back a wet fur bow
revealing the fallen beast in a tangle
of fireweed
this dark antlered 5x5 was my best bowl
to date i remember every detail of these
hunts like they were yesterday hence the
saying the beast is dead long live the
mighty beast bowhunting had gotten in my
soul at that time i had no idea
how it would end up directing my every
step through the journey of life
jack
despite my growth and success in bow
hunting i was still going nowhere in my
life i was 22 to 23 years old it's such
a good contrast like you're kicking ass
out in the woods yeah and yet
22 to 23 years old living with four guys
drank beer all the time one of my
roommates got two duis in three weeks
both while driving my truck i was glad i
hadn't i wasn't driving those times it
was just a matter of luck
more more a matter of luck than good
decision making i just never got caught
i wasn't living healthfully and still
didn't have a real sense of purpose i
wasn't accountable for anything or
anybody
i felt shitty all the time a wake-up
call arrived when i crashed my truck
one night while driving drunk
i was driving too fast and flipped the
vehicle rolling it the roof was crushed
all the way down to the top of the seat
the truck was totaled of course i didn't
remember a thing
damn just straight blackout driving wow
i could have easily died or killed
someone
did i wake up no not yet did i see some
connection between me walking away from
the crash and my dad walking away from
his was i falling in his alcoholic
footsteps my life had become a living
living with a bunch of guys just
partying basically working during the
week going to clubs and weekends just
drinking at the apartment or on the lake
it was a great life
those that i would usually on the
weekends i would get up
and go we lived on the second floor of
the chase village apartments and i'd go
out and look and see if my truck was
there
and i was i had driven my truck
and i'd have to go see
so if the truck was in there i'd go back
in and i'd be like where's my truck oh
don't you remember you left it the
scandia days or whatever the hell it's
like
no
damn
so it's just you know just being an
idiot yeah
uh
you say the same year i killed my first
bill in 1989 i wrote my first hunting
article bulls bugles and botches for
western bow hunters so you get into
writing pretty quickly out of the gate
with this um it's cool in the book you
got a bunch of the articles
clipped out um
so you're on this kind of
well i'll use your word
loser path yeah i use
normally i wouldn't say that but you got
it in the book you say being a loser
isn't cool but you know what's worse
than that being a loser dad
when tanner our first son was born in
1993 something inside of me switched
they say parenthood changes everything
and it did for me suddenly i wasn't just
on my own now i was affecting other
people's lives
i got to be an example
alcohol was poison i had seen what
alcohol did to my dad ruining what he
could have been something incredible and
i was seeing it do the same thing to me
so i stopped drinking
alcohol wasn't going to help me in any
area of my life especially with my
hunting i'm not judging anybody else but
for me i had to quit drinking
so
tanner coming along is really
the
seems like from the book it's the
catalyst for real change in your life
yeah i mean and you know people always
say and maybe it's true for them but
they say well
you know
uh
i don't know there's this thing like if
your father's an alcoholic then you have
a greater chance to be an alcoholic and
like this it keeps this this whole thing
going right
and then people learn from it this and
that and it all sounds good um i didn't
really
i knew all that i didn't really care
even when tanner was born i felt
different and i was like
okay i
this isn't just me being a
a 20 some year old
guy just going to the clubs that's what
it just feels like everybody does but
then with the kid but then still i
didn't it
i was like i should i probably shouldn't
be
a [__] like this but i still was i
still i'd not drink for a little while
then i'd you know whatever go go back
out
um
you know tanner was around so my wife we
were just in our 20s you know mid-20s
and uh i wasn't i was still doing stupid
[__] and then so it wasn't just like
right when he was born
it still took a while right and i still
was still [__] up um
you know i mean i would still drink and
drive i remember leaving the oregon
football game driving over all the cones
and this cop jumped out told me to pull
over and i was just why am i driving
over the cones i don't know it's
halftime been drinking the for the
for the whole game
and uh i had to do a a walking test like
a dui test there with everybody leaving
the oregon football game you know and
somehow i passed i have no idea how but
i never got a dui but the point is it's
like
it still took a little bit it wasn't
just a light switch i still
you know i hadn't run run a marathon yet
so i hadn't really tapped into like
dedication i was having success with the
bow i was having a little thing i still
didn't have a great job
what was your job at this time were you
still i was still in that warehouse so i
worked at that warehouse i was part-time
then i quit school and i got full-time
and uh
guys would kind of listen to me so they
made me a lead and
i worked there for nine years and then
by kind of by the end of that nine years
i was
starting to figure things out a little
bit and i got this job same job i have
right now at springfield utility board
and it's like you know
like we're here in san diego san diego
water and power whatever it's called
that's always a good good job and for me
for somebody like me
a job at a
municipal utility
it's about as good as it's gonna get
right it's you know people are always
gonna need water and power i'm gonna
have a paycheck good benefits it's like
okay this is like kind of total
stability yeah yeah and i could provide
for my family i still felt like a kid
but i'm like god i'm supposed to have
all these
you know these pay all these bills and
have cars and have this house and do all
this but i didn't feel like
i i don't know it just felt like still
like a lot for me
and uh so i ended up getting the job on
the construction crew at the springfield
utility board and uh
yeah so i started there at at like seven
dollars an hour i'd moved up
at the warehouse i was
they promoted me to supervisor the same
day i gave my notice and quit because i
got hired at the utility but so i was
making like 13 there and then i had to
go back down to seven to start at the
at the utility board but yeah so just
trying to get it figured out yeah
uh
back to the hunting a little bit you say
in the book it's been said that life
offers two paths one easy and one hard
as roy and i entered the unforgiving
sanctuary of the eagle cap wilderness
for the first time and witness the awe
inspiring
walawa how do you say that
walawa mountains in northeastern oregon
it was obvious that we had chosen the
latter
we were always drawn toward the more
difficult path to us harder was always
better
this is talking about um roy a little
bit here bow hunting in general is hard
there are lots of tough men who do it
but it's not easy the mountains can
break even the toughest man roy roth is
the toughest human i ever met and ever
seen out in the mountains hands down roy
was the toughest bow hunter i'd ever
seen and he always carried the best
attitude i learned so much from him he
is a big part of the reason i am the
person i am today as a kid i always knew
roy was good in the woods we would he
could always get the to the best fishing
holes before the rest of us we nick
nicknamed him gazelle roy because he was
big but moved like a gazelle he was a
great athlete he played football and he
was really good at baseball playing
third baseman from the moment roy told
me i should start bow hunting we
connected and hit it off from then on we
started hunting together and we just
clicked because we had no limits on how
much misery we could suffer to chase
success
so you guys roll out
into this uh this mountain wilderness
area
and
and uh
you you encounter another hunter who
tells you guys about this spot
where
billy cruz
used to go what's what's the legend of
billy cruz billy cruz was just a badass
uh started oregon bow company which was
the bow i shot at that time
in junction city back there in uh in
oregon and so
i actually didn't know billy cruz i knew
of him and seen his pictures well this
dentist that was in the wilderness he's
like
i said you know we've just we've came
from this trailhead way back here
something like 20 miles away
i said we just want to get away from
people.
he's like oh okay he goes well
um
i can send you to a place and nobody
goes he goes it's it's you know too
rugged for horses too steep for men all
this stuff and he goes the only person
that ever goes there is billy cruz
and uh
that sounds good you and roy are like
yeah yeah
it was awesome
and so
that was
but also i kind of i i did learn
something from that too because what i
was i learned at that time and it's been
proven over and over again
is
rugged country like that if men who
spend a lot of time in it
die
often it's just part of
them the mounds are so unforgiving and
billy cruz died back there and he died
in a plane crash but it's like if
while he's scouting elk in those
mountains
and uh
i just
it just gets proven over and over again
it's like you know people go and they
get a taste of the mountains they come
back but the longer you spend there the
more you're kind of you know you're just
playing this you roll on the dice and uh
but in the meantime um we did go there
and i ended up hunting back in that same
country for many years roy moved to
alaska after that first season but yeah
it was it was amazing we never saw
anybody back there
super rugged
uh this is kind of cool
you you say your one of your favorite
books of all time is hunting with the
bow and arrow by dr saxton pope written
in 1923 and you call out a couple parts
on page 181 it reads we also began
preparing ourselves for the contest
although habitually in good physical
condition we undertook special training
for the big event in this case he and
young were preparing for a grizzly bow
hunt pope continues by running the use
of dumbbells and other gymnastic
practices we strengthened our muscles
and increased our endurance
regarding the back country hunt he
writes
we were there to win and nothing else
matter mattered adding later we we were
trained down to the rawhide and sinew
keyed to alertness and ready for any
emergency
it seems like that could be like the
root of
you saying hey i can get in freaking
better shape for this [__] yeah i mean
there's a hundred years ago yeah and
those guys knew that at that time that
hey we need to bait out our best to be
in these mounds and and get animals
killed with an arrow
100 years ago these guys are freaking
training training yeah
did you like make that connection
no
because when i started training
so hunting the the hunter community
um is steeped in tradition obviously
the tradition isn't guys like
saxon pope and art young it's guys that
like maybe my stepdad who they're just
getting away going to deer camp they're
not we're not training for this you know
this is kind of a vacation
um
so when i first got into and i started
doing this running and doing this thing
like hey i need to be a little better i
got a lot of pushback from the hunting
community itself like saying you know
you don't need to run a marathon to kill
an elk but i know this guy and that guy
and they kill
animals all the time and they're
overweight and roy was actually over you
know he's a big dude overweight but the
difference is he was just so much
tougher and better than most guys so
they but they'd use that as an example
of why you don't need to be in shape
and i'd be like well okay you're not roy
first of all
and
but i got for years pushed back and
still probably still do i just don't pay
attention to them but people hunters
just don't want to because it kind of
puts the onus back on them like god do i
have to take this [__] more serious what
do i got to do here
[Laughter]
so
like you said roy moves to alaska mm-hmm
and you you go
it's for it's pretty not funny is not
the word but you can't find anybody else
really to hunt with no he must have been
one of those bastards just like strong
and can just carry his weight it's no
factor no he i mean there's a i can't
remember if i talk about it in there but
one time we were on prince of wales
island here's his attitude wrapped up
to hunt prince of wales for black bear
you need a boat it's all on the island
chain you got to go to open water
sometimes
uh there's tides coming in and out so
there's there's the water is pretty
dangerous out there but we had boat
motor problems and
without a boat
the motor running right out there it was
not only dangerous but you couldn't get
anywhere
so he's like i'm gonna
take this motor off and and go go into
town craig alaska which is
there in southeast alaska and but it's
about 15 miles on the water and he had
this little like 10 or 12 foot raft that
he had to put a piece of plywood on put
the motor on and kind of lay down and
kind of hold the front of it because to
get on step
that that it was coming up you know
and so he would have to lay and he did
15 miles
all the way in there on a sunday bought
this new motor for 4 000 bucks
and it's all the way i don't know he got
a ride on a actually a big ship and i
could see him i would see him coming the
next day and i'm like looking and i'm
like
i think i see roy on there and they're
like towing this little raft
tied to a rope behind it and i'm like
so anyway it was what and he did this at
midnight when he took off he's like well
no we this is what we got just by
himself by himself
and went in bought this you know 4 000
dollar motor
brought it back out we're back in
business kill and bear but that that
whatever it took yeah that's the
attitude right there well hey oh this
isn't working here's what we got to do
whatever it takes to make this happen
most people aren't like that yeah no
that's that's next level yeah
you say then after he moves to alaska
for the next 12 years i ended up hunting
in the sprawling unforgiven eagle cap
wilderness most of the time on my own
my entire existence seemingly revolved
around preparing for just one crack at
the wilderness bulls and bucks where
billy cruz had walked i learned more
about myself
on those solo hunts than i could have in
a lifetime in the everyday world
one of the things you learn you talk
about are you willing to bleed in most
cases it takes some blood to achieve
your goals the farther you go the fewer
who will be able to go or be willing to
go with you
i knew that if i could get back farther
into the wilderness
i could find better hunting i could get
away from other hunters if i was in
better shape and if i was mentally
stronger i could outlast anyone this is
sort of like this it's it's really cool
to read the book and there's so many
good details in here to see your
evolution as you're
kind of pioneering
this attitude of like oh i can just out
work and go further and i'll end up
being alone out there yeah and that's
what i want that's that was the only way
i could up my odds you know now
now we get to go hunt some great country
you know money can get get you that
opportunity um or knowing the right
people can get you that opportunity so
that ups your odds a little bit it's
still very hard you know as you know
still very hard but
you'll earn opportunity so but for me at
that time the only way to earn
opportunity
was
you know
i had no advantage i had no money
advantage all people in the regular
society
they're smarter more money more
connections more whatever i was down at
the bottom in the mountains i'm like
okay
i call the shots back here now all those
advantages you have on the outside don't
mean [__] back here now if i'm in better
shape than you and i know this country
better and i'm willing to to work harder
than you
this is this is my country this is i
call the shots i this is my domain i'm
i'm laughing and smiling over here
because
all the money in the world isn't going
to carry your ass up that freaking hill
that's it and that's the first time i
ever felt like you know because i
hadn't felt like [__] my whole life you
know as far as
i don't know what where i stood in on i
guess a ladder of success
and now all of a sudden i'm like
wait a second this is different it felt
different
the challenge for me at that time was
trying not to be i was
i mean i was selfish because
it's uh
i mean i found something that like for
me was good but now i had family home so
i'd be back there all the time and i'd
be like
should i be back away from my family
because it wasn't like a job
and were you making any kind of
connection towards what it could turn
into no just or use just me no i was
just you know this is just what i wanted
to do so it was like a selfish thing
because people can justify all the time
well i gotta do this for work so i gotta
travel for work and it's like it gives
us it's easy to say well
you know people have to do that we're
providing for the family something like
that
i'm gonna sell an article for 50 bucks
and be away from my family for 10 days
that doesn't pencil out but it's just
like i felt like that's
what i needed to do because when i
wasn't doing that i was at home i was
miserable then i felt like maybe i
wanted to go drinking or maybe how am i
getting this
you know like a buzz i guess
but
i used to get home from work at like
six o'clock maybe seven o'clock at night
walk in
put my work bag down pick up my jiu
jitsu bag and go to jiu jitsu for two
hours
and i did that every night i did that
every night and i remember sometimes
where my wife would be looking at me
with
with just like
a combination of anger and um
and lack of understanding like not like
like what what what are you serious
right now like this is what you're doing
you got three kids and you're
you're home for nine minutes and you're
gonna leave right and i did that
i did that every night
and um
you know when i when
what was interesting was my wife
eventually realized that if i didn't do
that
i had
i wouldn't i would be
a bad i would be i wouldn't be happy i
would be like
like not not have a good attitude about
stuff right because i felt like that was
what i needed to do
and
yeah there's
i i unfortunately i never really thought
about it as being selfish until you just
said that right now i guess i realized
that even at the time
but
i always kind of
kind of rationalized this thing where
i'd kind of relate it to my regular job
where i'd say well hey you know i need
to be able to do this in case i end up
in a situation where
i got to use this stuff in combat and
that'd be kind of my rationalization i
i'd even try and rationalize that to my
wife sometimes but my wife's not an
idiot and she'd be like hey listen you
you got freaking a rifle a pistol and
two knives and you think you're gonna
have to choke a personality on the
battlefield yeah
so
yeah it's i i think it is
you know you have some uh
some
like primordial
urges as a as a human
you know to fight or to hunt
like it seems like it's almost caveman
brain
for me it got really focused on fighting
for you it got really focused on hunting
both those are
total
primal instincts to have you know
so
here's an example you got the book of
how you're living your life on friday
afternoon and leave work around 4 p.m
driving through the north portland
through north portland arriving at 1am
at my eagle cap trailhead i'd load up my
pack and start walking try to get 12
miles or so in by first light i wouldn't
sleep get back in there by first light
saturday morning be able to hunt or
scout until sunday then i would hike out
and drive home sunday night
being back at work on monday morning two
nights no sleep two days scouting or
hunting
if it was the season it was worth it
these trips gave me the confidence to do
my long solo haunts i was testing myself
passing each test what what caught me
what caught me on that one was like
this isn't even hunting season this is
you're just going out there to scout and
get to know the terrain
yeah so it's uh your wife is pissed
right i mean and i
so it kind of is frustrating a little
bit
and i don't at that time i wasn't like
oh i'm going to prove all these people
wrong i mean kind of i was proving
people wrong i felt like but
it was more like i just felt like i
would needed to do that or i wanted to
do that maybe to be selfish
um but now
people see like where you are now and
you write a book or you know you're
teaching leadership and
you know there's like people see
everything like you get a lot of
attention because
now you're somebody
but it was the dues you paid going to
every night you'd go to training after
work or if i do that
the reason why you get to hear is
because you you
had all that sacrifice you made all
those sacrifices for time and for work
and it's just like i wanted to ask those
people what the [__] are you doing
what your word i mean what where have
you sacrificed yeah of course it's easy
to be envious of this when you're like
oh you got this many followers and
you're sponsored or this or that it's
like
yeah that's
what about all the grind
and the grind where i would be back
there and i'd be like i shouldn't be
back here and i should be at home i
should be being a dad and i should be
this or that and then i'd be like well
you can and
you kind of alluded to you can justify
almost anything
and be like well no i'm not going to be
happy if i'm back here and i'll be a
better dad when i get home and i'll be
you know i'm showing my my kids and when
i got a little older i'd be like well
i'm showing i'm an example for my kids
and showing them what hard work can lead
to i 100 percent use that that one 100
as a matter of fact i told i
i would tell like other seals you know
if they would say get worried about hey
you know i'm going on deployment again
i'd say listen man guys have been going
on deployment
for thousands of years and leaving their
kids at home and that's the example that
the kids see you know that the dad's
going on deployment by the way when you
went on deployment
back in freaking
whatever
500 years ago your deployment was seven
years long right your deployment was
five years even world war ii in world
war ii you went you left for war
in 1941 or 1942 and you came home when
it was over yeah
that's some commitment yeah so
because guys we get well the reason that
this would get brought up was guys would
get worried about primarily they'd be
worried about like their sons
hey you know i feel like you know i'm
leaving my son too much and i said hey
the moms have been raising young
warriors
for thousands of years right you don't
need to worry about that they're they're
going to look at you and think hey this
is what this is what i'm supposed to do
yeah so they'll figure it out but i
that sometimes that justification would
kind of turn into some rationalization
for me traded jiu jitsu on a thursday
night after i've been
freaking training all week or whatever
well and the dads have to be gone for
the moms to be able to use uh wait till
your dad gets home
true
that that's how they raise those
warriors
[Laughter]
uh
speaking of all this i'm a worker the
truth is i've always worked really hard
because i've never really felt like i
had a ton of natural skills or talent it
would feel unnatural for me not to have
a regular job
i feel like such a life is reserved for
someone who's a star and i don't think i
got that so i grind it out i grind it
out at training and i grind it out at
work not taking a day off is my only
edge i can't just say you know today i'm
not gonna run i've sacrificed enough no
that's what everybody does everybody has
an excuse everybody has a reason you can
always come up with a reason not to go
after a challenge
so i've learned to never care what the
excuse is it's never valid
that's my attitude and that's my edge
it's how i've built endurance and
fostered resiliency
there are no rest days in my schedule
and that's is the reason i excel
i think it's like no factor no factor
well people say like oh you take rest
days i'm like life life gives you rest
days yeah you know you get the freaking
broken water heater and all of a sudden
you're dealing with that or you know you
get a travel day where it's like hey
i'm gonna be traveling at whatever time
and then the plane
lays over and you're in the airport for
four hours in your layover and like okay
life is gonna give you rest days right i
don't take them voluntarily it's not
happening well i have a hard time like
even yesterday uh
you know rihanna went out and evan was
out skydiving and andy was out there too
and uh i was i paid to actually go and
i'm like
i actually want to go on a run
so i did 14 miles here went up to the
top of the hill over here ran along the
beach and
just would rather work instead of
skydiving
so i i don't know maybe i missed out on
something but
it's uh i just don't i feel better
i don't know i just don't feel good
unless i've sacrificed
you know sweated worked
so i can go to bed at night and be like
well got it done today yeah we just had
a guy on the podcast named andrew
huberman
and he's a neuroscientist oh i love him
yeah he's a stud but he one of the
things that he was one of the points he
was making is that
free dopamine
dopamine that you don't earn is like the
worst thing in the world so dopamine
that you get from your uh from your
phone yeah dopamine that you get from a
chocolate chip cookie dopamine that you
get that you didn't have to earn is like
the worst thing in the world
and that's probably what you feel is you
probably feel like if you don't earn
that dope i mean it doesn't feel right
yeah i mean
and people always say you over train or
you've heard all the sleep thing people
love talking about or you get enough
sleep and
and uh i don't know i just
i just don't i don't care about any of
that i i mean i'm gonna train every day
i'm probably not gonna get enough sleep
but it's like that that is the only edge
yeah just to
sacrifice more that's the only reason
why anybody knows who i am
hard work
by the way this whole time you're
writing for uh
for bow hunting magazines
local magazines
uh you get rejected
you get rejected by bowhunter magazine
you you write about that there
which is
i mean
that's what happens right yeah that's
what happens
uh then you say i decided to write my
first book bow hunting trophy black tail
there was never any grand plan one day i
decided i wanted to write a book and i
wanted to be badass hardback full cover
um
so
you do that
and
you have to borrow a bunch of money to
get the thing published yeah it's like
what 50 grand yeah it was 50 000. no i
because the book was like over 10
dollars each because it was full color
for like glossy paper and i didn't know
anything about anything
so i made
uh
5 000 of them 50 000 bucks i had
like maybe 200
of it so i borrowed
i think 15 000 from my grandma uh 10 000
from my other from my in-laws my mom i
think 15. anyway what year was that that
was 99. so like the internet isn't
around yet no you can't even sell this
thing on the internet really no no you
need to have a magazine how long were
those freaking boxes of books sitting
around the house for years
years i mean we moved them a couple
times had a whole spare bedroom filled
was at 5 000 books and they're heavy too
yeah that is not fun no and it took you
know i and your wife's like dude i know
you spent 50 grand and now we got one
less room in our house i know
it was like was not penciling out if
this was a business plan hey what's your
business plan i never did that one time
yeah i never even knew how much the
books were going to be
until they said well here's what you owe
us
so the i'm like no i'm writing a book i
don't
uh i'll self-publish it because nobody
said the market's not big enough because
it's just black-tailed deer which is
just on the west coast of oregon
washington california and bc
and uh
so yeah it took forever just to even
make that money back but i paid
everybody back
it took a while what'd you sell the
books for
i think like 20 bucks i think 25 okay
yeah and then five shipping so it's like
maybe 29.95 with everything
yeah and packing them up yourself yeah
oh i know
yeah
it was uh yeah one thing that's awesome
about this story though is i mean your
story your life is that you just took
something that you love to do
and just for all in like that's what
that's what you're doing
yeah and that's i mean i don't
i don't know i don't know why how it's
worked like this but it's just been my
journey but like i've never been like
well i want to meet tiger woods so i'm
going to try to golf you know what i
mean it's like everything i've done i've
met a lot of amazing people only through
what i do
it's never been like just to meet these
so i've i've been able to train with
olympians and do all this thing just
because it's like no they're helping you
know i care about this to build
endurance so i'm going to run with an
olympian to see what i can learn from
them or to train with these the these
biggest bad asses or to or to lift
weights with these studs you know mark
bell
i can have those chances to interact
just
through my thing i'm not i haven't
changed anything that i do it's just
what i do but it's a it's
staying true to
i'm a bow hunter and my instagram bio
just says bow hunter
and because of that i've met i'm sitting
here with you guys
how incredible is that
i mean
it just doesn't
seem real that's funny because i'm
thinking the same thing over here
i'm like hey this is freaking awesome uh
you did and eventually you got into bow
hunter and um
your first your first thing that you
wrote and this was in 2009 was called
bleed yeah
hell yeah
uh
now we get into this little section of
your life i'm gonna fast forward i
started running just for the test to
push myself up to 2000 the most i'd ever
run was a 10k then one time i entered a
7.3 mile race in salem oregon and
guys thought i was crazy for running
that far just to get in shape to hunt
the blacktail woods around home then i
ran a half marathon then in 2003 i ran
my first marathon and finished third
overall
your first marathon you finished third
that's freaking legit
this was about the time i really began
to notice that my physical condition
could pay play a huge impact hunting in
the woods this was where i could improve
my game
and it wasn't like that was a boston
marathon i got third in it was like a
pretty small marathon in in the gorge so
it's from the dallas to hood river but i
did get third still yeah the hell yeah
uh since that first marathon of complete
competed in ultramarathons when in peak
shape prior just prior to bow season i
run at least 20 miles a day
i've ramped it up an effort to gain not
only physical mental strength
and it's paid off in many years of
consistent
success
uh
you do the bighorn trail run that's your
first ultra yeah which alters anything
over uh 26.2
yeah um
you got this for your yeah you've been
writing your whole life kind of and it
shows in this book
three awesome stories you say i led the
race until mile 24 25. the problem was
the race didn't end at mile 24 or 25.
yeah
32 miler
uh
i finished second overall with a time of
four hours and 53 seconds it was a great
day to be alive
on almost all the races i run at some
time or another i want to stop and throw
in the towel similarly on many tough
hunts i want to quit and go home to the
good life so why don't i quit what
resides in me to keep going maybe it's
because i don't want to let people down
because i'm a regular guy coming from a
small a regular small town who dared to
dream big about being special and
finding some success in life maybe i've
always felt like proving people wrong as
i started running marathons i realized
the connection between endurance racing
and hunting because in both disciplines
you're facing huge barriers that make
you want to quit no one's going to judge
you if you quit a hunt most people would
fail on a hunt the same goes for an
ultra marathon not many could call you a
failure if you didn't last to the finish
of a long ultra because most people you
know likely wouldn't even tow the
starting line but to me
failure feels
feels like all those people who've
doubted me over the years were right
i can't have that
so now you've got the full-on
connection between the better shape i'm
in the better i can hunt
yeah it's uh i just
i mean i noticed that i was just at
i had a big advantage over people i
could see people get fatigued if i was
with somebody i could just it was just
different and i'm like
i learned that if the hardest thing
you've ever done is that hunt
that's bad it's not good you're gonna
because you're gonna you'll [__] up so
much you have to be on such
i mean precision and making good
decisions
it's a you have to be at your very best
so if you're fatigued or if if you're
thinking about home or all these
different things
um it's taken away from where your focus
should be you will fail
and i just i noticed that
or i realized i need to be at my very
best even at the end of a long hunt and
how it made sense to me was that at the
end of a long hunt instead of being
diminished you should be better because
you're getting more dialed into the
mountains you're understanding the
animals and their habits you're getting
more mountain tough and so if you
weren't fatigued or have any of those
things
with uh time that comes in the mountains
like that wears on people if that wasn't
wearing on you
by the end of that hunt you're going to
be
at your very best and i killed a lot of
animals at the very end of the hunt
so
uh at one point the oregonian newspaper
ran an article
and the headline reads bowhunter beats
armstrong
tell us that story it's in the book but
give us a give us a background on that
one
yeah i mean i knew so lance was retiring
from the tour de france and he had won
seven
straight it's that next year
was let me think i think that was in
2006 he ran the new york marathon
and i'd been a big big lance fan you
know this is what before all the
whatever people want to say about peds
and all that it's before all that so he
was just like had overcome this and he
was like a hero he's still somebody i
look up to just because he was the best
of the very best of what he did
so he's running this marathon the new
york marathon and it's my first year
running it it's uh it's kind of hard to
get into it's a big race
and so i thought well i want to try to
be the greatest endurance athlete of all
time and so i ended up i beat him there
it was in 2006
and then we ran together actually a
little for half the race in in boston in
2008 and i beat him there too
of course it was like a one
person
he didn't even know who i was so it was
it wasn't like this is a cam vs lands
head to head he was
you know he was a superstar i was just
some dude
you know it's like if lebron james goes
to open gym and somebody you know
somehow
travels and gets some hook shot to go in
they dominated lebron so it's kind of
like that yeah he didn't know it's like
it's like beating someone at open mat or
you're like someone passes your guard
open map they're like hey you know i
crushed jocko passed this card like yeah
i didn't even know that we were you know
i was out there having fun we're rolling
right so so i was the guy who passed
your guard
and lance was you and you somehow it
makes the cover of the oregonian right
now jaco's guard gets passed by boho
exactly
it was so unjustified but it's
hey i just all i cared about was there
is that it just referred to me as
bowhunter yeah that's badass
it reminds me of you know just everybody
everybody loves the movie 300 but do you
remember what he was like well you know
what's your professional your profession
that's such a great part
and then so
i don't have a that's what i do is boho
now did you talk to him during those two
races didn't one of them you ran with
him for a while and you were like
talking right right yeah yeah
who knows if he'll remember i think we
we did send him a book though but but oh
i was going to say sir you're not
connected now
i'm supposed to do his podcast oh okay
well we've never talked about this yeah
like me he and i
but he's gonna be like i let you win
i don't know he'll be like what i don't
even know who who you are but what i
remember
this could be a version
you know how you could you tell
something
a story to yourself so many times it's
like it becomes the truth it never
happened but it's like now it's like i
remember roy told me this one time he's
like we went on this moose hunt
and i've been like yeah i've never have
i actually never had a shot at a moose
and he's like
you
you blew it on a giant bull and i'm like
when he goes remember on the river and
the pouring rain and you hit low on that
giant bull on the other side of the
river and i was just like
oh my god
that i i had totally blocked that out of
my memory i had turned i had made this
truth in my head that i'd never shot at
a moose
no i just didn't want to remember when i
blew it i had definitely shot it on and
blew it so anyway who knows if this
lands story is kind of like this but all
i know is
we were running and i was running behind
him and i i was hurting just dying like
30 mile 13 of the race and i remember
was behind him he had this gold singlet
on like he always wore because like a
call to the tour
and uh i was looking at his calves and i
was like god he's probably just feels
strong he's not tired at all not fatigue
and i was like god why can't i be an
olympic athlete you know he made the
olympics too
and i just thought he was probably just
fresh as can be and i'm just this
[__] 40 year old dad dying
and uh i get up i'm like okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna go i don't care how bad this
hurts i mean i might just you know burst
into flames puke throw up collapse who
knows what's gonna happen so i fight
fight fight takes me a while and i get
up beside him
so we're running side by side
and uh
he goes
he looks over probably because i was
staring at him in the nose
maybe i was touching his arm i don't
know
but uh
he goes
he goes does this heartbreak hill and i
said no not yet i said it's still up
here it's like oh [__] i'm dying and i
was just like oh
i'm dying too but i didn't know you were
dying so that gave me like a weird boost
yeah you know this this man god is dying
and here i'm a regular
man and i'm dying so it's like okay so
we kept going kept going and he ended up
saying hey what's your pace today and i
told him he's like do you mind
who knows if this happened i think it
did but
he said do you mind if i run with you
and i'm like no it's like yeah they're
250 so we ran together and yeah it's
just like
shared a few words i remember people
like let's what ten thousand times i
remember this one guy ran up by him and
he's like he goes i had testicular
cancer too
lance is like
i mean we're running this race and it's
like i don't even know how you're
supposed to respond
you know so
it was just a weird but i was right
there for all this anyway we
i i uh
i was finished 12 seconds i think or
something ahead of him in that race but
we had this connection yeah yeah so it's
so much so
the only reason why maybe i didn't make
it up so even though even though we're
saying that it was the race between you
and you and him but it was really only
in your mind yeah
when someone starts pulling ahead of you
in a run that's a thing right so like
at some point you had to start pulling
ahead of him right
yeah i mean he had this there's a mo uh
motorcade around him because the vamp
the
the elites finished at probably two
maybe ten two eight 208. and we were
back at 2 50. so um
they had finished so then the story for
the tv was lance because lance was
running boston so there's like this
motorcycle and had a camera on it and
all the stuff and so yeah there's some
overhead shots and when we were on tv
and my wife you know i had told my boys
this is in the book too but i told my
boys that hey i'm going to go to boston
and
uh i'm going to beat lance armstrong in
the race again lance doesn't know
anything about me but anyway they
thought i was like
you know just talking out my ass they
were they were laughing you can't beat
lance armstrong because they'd been
watching him in tv forever
and he was such a legend in the in the
tour you know he'd just you know cocky
and blow by people and just dominate and
rub it in their face and it's like so it
was like you know
he had this
this thing about him and
this aura
so i said i was going to go back to run
with them and then beat him at the end
they laughed and so then on tv
i'm running with lance armstrong i have
this camo top on that i cut the sleeves
off of he's got all his nike gear
and
there i am and we're running and then so
at the end i'm like well i
told myself i'm not going to [__] run
this whole way and not do what i said so
i took off
and and came across
um and he had his own finish line so he
had to go veer over to the right but
um the reason why i think maybe i didn't
make all of it up 100 was because he
finished and then he pointed at me
i like i went over there and
and we shook hands and said you know
good job so we had a he
whatever so and they got a picture i
can't remember if it's in the book or
not it is but uh yeah so i mean it was
for me
dude that was
that was that felt like i was almost
athletic you know at that time i was
like this is
this it would be like winning a gold
medal i thought
so it was and you got home and your kids
were you told your kids like so they saw
it no they saw it they watched it they
were well true was at home he's watching
and then here's how big a deal lance was
at the time they announced it on the
school intercom
that
tanner and truitt's dad beat lance
armstrong in the boston marathon
so
you know
eugene is known as as a running capital
of the world you know we have the
olympics olympic trials there all the
time so running is kind of a big thing
there so to ha and everybody knows
boston everybody knows lance so it's
like his perfect storm
but it for me it was that big where do
you record with him
i don't know we have to schedule it oh
okay yeah i was going to say if you get
this podcast out hopefully you won't
hear this one before he gets you out
because otherwise oh yeah i totally
remember you yeah i don't i don't know
either i will be ready for you i know
he'll be like no yeah that did not
happen
all right so uh speaking of running
here we go with over 17
000 feet of elevation gain the big horn
100 was one of the toughest hundred mile
foot races in the united states it would
be my first ultra over 50 miles the
previous year at the bighorn 50 i
finished third overall it would be my
first race where i would be required to
run through the night
my wife was having second thoughts and
tried to persuade me to reconsider
you said i've already done a 50 miler my
goal is to find out exactly what i can
do
to find where's my breaking point
so at this point you've done some 50
milers and now you're going for the
hundo yeah because
in the ultra marathon world
it's
until you do 100
it doesn't even
it's like i don't know they just don't
even really count it
you know like the 50k which is 32 miles
or the 50 mile it's like well have you
done 100 yet so that's like the
barrier of entry for the ultra world
yeah
and i hadn't so that was my first one
and you say the bighorn 100 is an out
and back run consisting of 76 miles of
single track trail 16 miles of rugged
double track jeep trail and eight miles
of gravel road with 17 500 feet of
climate 18 000 feet of descent
so i looked at the map of this i went
online and looked it looked like
so it sort of looks like
uh you're going up and down mountains
the whole time you're going on a ridge
line or something well what is it or in
and out of mountains no you're
so it starts um you start pretty high
and then you go you go up to 9000 feet
then you stay on the ridge then you drop
all the way down to maybe 6 000 feet and
then you climb back at the 48 mile mark
as a turnaround
and that climbs from 6 000 back up to
about almost 10 000 probably nine
something
but it's a gradual climb up and then you
reverse and come back that's what
struck me as very sucky
when i looked at it because i was like
oh you know it kind of looks like
because they have a profile shot where
they kind of just show you the elevation
and it's up down it's basically up down
up down up down up down kind of
descending right up down up down up
you're kind of slowly descending
and and then i read your book and i was
like oh and there's a turn around right
so you go up down up down up down up
down up down and you're kind of
descending and then it's up down up down
up down up down up but going back up
yeah that there's a grind from i
remember this specifically from i think
60 something to 82
and
so hard
it was so just it was up the whole way
and it's starting to get hot
and it's like you'd been running all
night
and you said uh even 20 miles into it
you borrowed a camel back from somebody
you got that thing wearing holes into
your back it did it i never trained with
it
and you went out of the gate like
pre-fontaine just got harder
well enough is like the 800 meter back
in middle school
uh
it was yeah and and i thought i was
going to get it to turn around quicker
so i didn't have a headlamp
because i thought it was going to be
there
i had my head here's what i'm gonna do
i'll get here it you know whatever it
right when it's starting to get dark but
i didn't get there till about 11
12 hours into the race and so it'd been
dark for a couple hours so i'm up in the
snow there's snow up there at the
turnaround
and post holing through the snow with no
light
and i get to turn around and i was like
oh my god this is brutal
so that was my first one that is 48
miles down i had 52 left
you say in here uh that that 48 mile
turn around the porcupine aid station is
a real convenient spot for dnfers
that was the official notation on the
race results for runners who'd quit dnf
did not finish i saw guys at porcupine
tough guys obviously i mean hell to get
there they just ran 48 miles to the last
18 uphill to the tune of a 4 500 foot
gain looking like they were on their
deathbed wrapped in blankets being
attended by medics it was that porcupine
that many called it a race
yeah i see
having been in the military for a long
time
i was in the military for a long time
and we would be going out on patrols
and you pay really close attention to
how much elevation you're going to gain
or lose you know when you're doing a map
study you're looking at the contour
lines like you're figuring out so when
you say
4500 feet gain or a total of 18 000
that
sucks yeah
it's it and that that's what makes it's
not just the distance it's the terrain
too and on trail also your body's like
correcting all the time
you know like on the road
you'll see some elite marathoners and
they don't even have abs you know they
kind of almost got a little pot belly
because you can get so efficient at
running on a road
in the mountains
you are correcting all your core is like
getting taxed your quads are getting
taxed it's a whole different type of
running but it's it's taxing
what are you carrying on you
uh you gotta take some water usually and
some calories so that's it
[Music]
you get you were trying to do it in how
long 24 hours yeah that's always the
goal if you can break 24 hours and 100
mile or you're it's legit you're legit
um
at 12 p.m i topped out at mile 82 i was
at 25 hours now
it's not under 24.
and i still had 18 miles left
by 3 10 p.m i reached the last aid
station at mile 95 when i got to mile 95
tanner was there waiting for me and ran
the last five with his old man that a
boy i told him i couldn't stop because
of my knee and said we had an hour and
50 minutes
to run five miles
yeah i wanted to i definitely wanted to
get in under 30 hours right yeah 29 so
and was tanner just like i mean you can
run you can run 5 miles in 30 minutes
yeah i mean he was i think 14 at the
time and i kind of took him just kind of
you know how we
we talked about we always try to justify
so i'm like well if my son's there it's
like i'm not really being selfish
so he had to stay in the hotel by
himself
for a whole day 29 hours i had somebody
give him a ride to that aid station to
go the last five
and he didn't even really want to do
five
so but i was going pretty slow at that
time
uh
at 4 20 p.m 100 miles were in the books
official time 29 hours 20 minutes i was
100 mile ultra marathoner i earned my
first 100 mile belt buckle
yeah that's what you get instead of a
a medal or a trophy or anything you do
get usually a bell bucket is that it is
that just like out west or is that
everywhere
uh
i don't know maybe out i'm not
sure yeah
check 100 miles yeah
fast forward a little bit here
you say
in the final year of my dad's life he
reminded me once again how much i
respected and admired him from the
moment doctors discovered a lump on his
liver bob haynes began his fight with
cancer it was an aggressive form of
cancer but he never gave up for 18
months he waged a war against it i'm
going to beat it he told me
everybody who gets cancer says this
and sometimes they do
so your dad
um
comes down with with liver cancer
you you you talk about that and here and
as you're talking about that
you still are working your job you're
still being a dad
and you're still training and you're
still running
and you have a goal
and you say the most coveted award in
the ultra marathoning world is the
silver buckle awarded at the western
states endurance run it's the most
famous 100 mile race in the world
because of its history and
competitiveness i earned my belt buckle
in my second 100 miler by finishing in
under 24 hours at 22 hours and 41
minutes in my world if there was ever a
comparison to an olympic gold medal it
would be this silver buckle
so you're gonna go for this thing on the
drive down to where the race started in
olympic valley california i talked to my
dad on the phone and he didn't sound
good
he'd been battling cancel for cancer for
a year and a half so i knew in my heart
he was nearing the end of his fight
as i ran i took some solace and knowing
he was following my progress live
on the ws100.com
one website
at 3 41 a.m i crossed the finish line in
auburn california and in doing so earned
my silver western states buckle
i just logged a nearly seven hour
improvement over my first hundred mile
race i started out the race supremely
confident but during those 22 hours and
41 minutes of reflection while running
doubt crept in more than once
through those struggles i kept telling
myself that my pain was temporary
in a few days time i would be healed up
and richer from the experience for my
dad there would be no healing
there would be there would only be
deeper and more debility debilitating
pain and sickness
than death
i finished the race that sunday morning
we drove home that day getting home very
late
i went to work the next day
i will never forget looking into dad's
eyes upon my return from the race and
saying dad i wish i could give you some
of my strength
don't give up on me yet he told he told
me
he still thought he was going to beat it
i will never forget his will to live
a handful of days after i earned my
silver buckle
in the western states race my dad passed
on early in the day on july 5th
the pain of losing him was much worse
than any i'd felt before from the races
life
or anything
yeah um
that
that was a
definitely a hard time
it's like a big transition because on
july 4th every year
there's the butte to butte 10k in eugene
my dad his how he lived with my stepmom
candy pretty close to the course so they
would walk down to dairy mart and we'd
be doing the 10k and run by him every
time every year forever and so i'm
running that that day july 4th 2010
the day before he died and i was getting
up there by dairy mart
no dad
and so
he never missed
you know like i said running is so
important that butte debuts the biggest
race in eugene
um
so it was uh
you know i mean i knew but
people with cancer it's like it's always
this thing i've known quite a few people
have it and everybody's going to beat it
and you just know and it just it's
heartbreaking because
they're not going to beat it the chemo
is going to
you know you can only take the chemo so
long so the the cancer is held back for
a while but then once you stop the chemo
because your body can't take it then the
cancer comes back
harder and it's like
everybody kind of knows the routine
but nobody wants to talk about it but i
knew
and
so then not seeing him there that day
and then uh you know then he died that
on early in the morning on july 5th and
had to go over there and you know uh
it was
it was just a
you know
when somebody dies at the house like he
did
you have to have the funeral home or
whoever the corner or whatever come over
so he comes over and he's by himself
and he my dad's room is upstairs and
he's like i said how are you
how are you getting them down
he's like well could you help me and so
we had to
put him in a bag and had to help carry
him out
and it's like uh
i don't know it's one of those
you just never forget never forget that
and so it's
just
death um this journey you know your dad
not being around it's like it makes all
the other like i say in there the
physical pain
seemed like nothing to me
what did your dad think about the
the freaking hundred mile races because
those weren't really around when your
dad was running no
he probably
i mean he he would act like he cared but
you know he was more of a
olympic
event person
pole vault high jump
running
you know the ultras are kind of like
kind of a weird offshoot of that you
know
so he's probably like well for
he'd probably think it was better than
bow hunting because he never hunted he's
just an athlete his whole life so he
would say
you know what i'd kill an animal i'd
lose brain cells
so he was like pretty liberal
south eugene's a pretty liberal school
in eugene uh and he was track coach
there forever so he never got the
hunting part but
he you know so the
ultras are probably a little better than
hunting he can celebrate those a little
more but still not quite as good as
you know real track yeah
i don't know there's something i don't
think like dads are ever impressed by
anything you do you're always just like
well you know
that's a tough that's a tough crowd yeah
the old man's a tough crowd for sure
yeah
i remember uh
i was with leif who i wrote extreme
ownership with and we made the new york
times bestseller list right and so
i i called my parents i was like hey um
you know and life remembers this because
i had him on speakerphone i was like hey
just found out we made the new york
times bestsellers list
and uh my mom's like well
it really what really counts is how long
you stay on there please
yeah i was like cool
all right yeah i was like cool later
get a good point yeah like cool yeah my
boss you know later
sorry about that yeah sorry bothered you
oh
[Music]
yeah i just wanted to taste that thing
i'll take the very bottom just taste it
one minute i'm gonna go on record saying
if the if your book doesn't
your book
it'll make it i'm i'm i'm going on
record as saying it'll make it it'll
make it dude
the freaking uh
the tour you're doing right now yeah
it'll make it
hopefully
um yeah and they're
you know it's not based on sales it's
based on
whatever their weird voodoo is yeah it
could be the upset of the century if it
makes it
well you know uh you know jordan
peterson's book 12 rules for life have
you ever heard of that yeah it's
literally the biggest selling book in
the past i don't know how long yeah it
didn't make it
so that is yeah i don't know yeah they
got their own little
they got their own things they're
promoting over there yeah um anyways
going back to this book you got a whole
section in here on a bunch of people
uh
courtney how do you say her last name
dewalter you got courtney dewalter
michael chandler conor mcgregor
conor mcgregor david goggins you talk
about jordan kobe br brady tiger steve
from
pre-fontaine you just got a bunch of
awesome freaking athletes and studs
um that you talk about kind of what you
take away from all them so that was a
pretty cool section and then like you
said
you've gotten to meet all these people
and freaking hang out with them yeah did
you did you meet tiger
no no no and not i just like their minds
yeah well jordan kobe brady and although
you you exchanged some uh some like
social media with
brady with brady
yeah and i have talked to connor before
but all i ever said to connor was this
is kind of he's on his come up
and he was like really taken off and he
was sitting there i was you know joe had
the hook up for the seats you know
god bless joe in the ufc but so conor
was sitting there with his girlfriend
and i go over there and i just said
i go um
i said
how have you ever lost because he had
two he has two had two losses at this
time
he was i think he's cage warriors or
whatever over there and then came up and
was on a pretty good tear in the ufc but
i was like
he has two losses and i said how have
you ever lost because you seem
unbeatable right now he's like well i
was just young just
wasn't that good
so anyway that was the only time i've
ever really exchanged words with him but
uh yeah i never met kobe but i i took a
lot and and jordan i haven't met him but
that mindset you know the winning
mindset everybody can take something
from those guys yeah how good was that
uh documentary the last dance oh my god
i loved it
loved it yeah
speaking of dads you know how well like
dad's never listened to anything that
you say right so my dad's a sports
fanatic a sports fanatic
and i go hey you should really watch
this thing the last dance i don't know
like it's
i i i can't get him to watch it he still
hasn't still hasn't watched it he's the
one person in the world who has watched
the one person in the world who is a
basketball fanatic coached because you
brought it up refereed basketball and i
said hey hey dad this is probably like
the coolest thing that's ever been made
about basketball
from a media perspective yeah you should
really watch it you will really enjoy it
yeah
you should have told him not to watch it
that's what i should do i should have
told him it was stupid
yeah
i know they did a such a good job
and jordan's mindset oh my god
how do you not i love when he's like
getting on the guys oh yeah yeah yeah
all those and then the next see i grew
up and you probably well see
you're older than me but by the time
jordan's time was here
i was already in the military so i
wasn't tracking as hard as i was as i
was in the 80s right when it was you
know the celtics and the lakers yeah and
me being from new england it was like
celtics 100 all day long and larry bird
is like a god oh yeah and then you have
larry because larry bird's attitude
is savage similar and you know the thing
that they say about bird and they say
this and you can go back and forth and
whatever but you know that bird wasn't
as athletic
as a lot of players in the nba but he
was just such a hard worker yeah that he
was going to outwork you right and
that's what he was going to do so my
mindset was always like i'm just going
to have to work harder yeah like bird
yeah
like and that you know my dad when i
played basketball if i didn't come home
with like skinned knees from diving on
the floor yeah that was like a fail
right exactly
well yeah me and tanner tanner was a
basketball player
and he
we had so many battles because i was
probably like your dad
and i would just be like pissed the
whole time watching him play he would
score 32 and a half one game
and i'm like
i'm like you're not even playing defense
yeah i am yeah i go you're not you're
not getting i said as soon as that ball
leaves their hand from whoever you're
guarding
it has to go all the way to the floor
and all the way back into the hand
during that time
why don't you dive on it
so
then he finally like years later now he
watched some old tapes from from high
school and he's like god dad he goes i
can't believe how lazy i was on defense
and i'm like no [__] we had but we had
so many fights about it yeah i suck by
the way no dessert no to everyone i
sucked at basketball i was a hustler
though i would just hustle i would i
would steal you know i'd play i would
play d yeah
um well that larry bird gave white guys
hope
but what people most people skip overs
he was also like what six six nine nine
yeah
so he's not like just a little white guy
he's and he could shoot better than
anybody yeah he was a beast yeah um
uh so you got that cool chapter you're
kind of talking about what you take away
from all those all those uh bad ass
individuals
then you've got a section here it's this
beast mode
there are no rest days as irrational as
it may seem in my mind i'm not good
enough to take a day off and i never
will be running training and bow
shooting have always been a therapy
of sorts for me
what i call my lift run shoot lifestyle
is a means to an end and that end is
hunting preparation is key to achieve
any goal you cannot fall back on luck or
talent those will leave you empty-handed
every time
you kind of made this point earlier and
i knew this part was coming
like you can't you can
theoretically not be in good shape
and go out and you can kill a bull it
can happen yeah
and i've heard stories from guides
telling me that there will be people
that show up to hunt that
they really haven't really even sighted
in their boat yet i know i know
it's
i couldn't imagine being god i would
hate to be i'd be like i don't know how
they just don't be like what are you
what in the hell is going on because
also
to me it's like it shows respect to the
animal when you show it prepared
you know when you're not prepared you're
you're shooting an arrow you can hit it
in the guts you hit in the ass hit it
now wherever it's like you
don't care about that animal's life so
much so literal or whatever how i worded
that wrong but i mean
it's so insignificant you can't prepare
for this hunt that to me i don't like
that
um
yeah and then what you're saying like
that's another underlying theme in your
book is like
sure you can theoretically do that
but if you everything that you can do to
be a little bit more prepared is going
to just up your odds a little bit yeah a
little bit more well i would always
think that i've always thought about
things in
in percentages and numbers and i'd
always think even in basketball so you
could go back because i played all these
sports but you know try to get this to
my kids and
whatever but it's like the so you're in
better shape so your reaction time is
probably a little quicker so if you can
get and it might just be one finger hits
that ball
that that slows that ball down enough
for the next guy down the line to where
that pass is going the ball is going
slower so they could get to the ball
knock it loose kick it to you you could
score whatever all and that started with
the fingertip which started with
preparation which started with reaction
time so it's like i'd always say
you can't measure some of this stuff
with these big big factors and big
numbers but it's percentage-wise even if
it's a tenth of a percent that adds up
so the more i can do to add those
percentages i'm just going to be that
much better
yeah and that one-tenth of a percent
that might be the one tenth the percent
that means success or failure yeah
because also i've thought about this in
terms of hunting where if that broadhead
blade
so i shoot heavy poundage also and
people want to criticize this you don't
need to shoot 90 pounds or whatever so
i'm always thinking that if that animal
reacts
and it's spinning when that arrow hits
and because that force that arrow is
greater where instead of kicking off the
bone and go and say to the right it
pushes through the bone
gets more penetration and maybe catches
that one artery with one blade and that
one blade cutting that artery because
you have higher poundage you were more
prepared and you got that arrow more
where you wanted it to that artery would
drip a blood that maybe you lost blood
and then you found the one drop that led
you the direction where then you found
the animal or more blood but it was that
one drop that did that
what caused that extra drop of blood
which can make all the difference in the
world
and it's like you can't tell me
all the [__] i think about and all the
work i put in doesn't make a difference
because you can't tell me that that's
not immeasurable yeah that's that's a
difference
i was shocked the first time i was
following a blood trail i was with
dudley
the the you are literally looking for
blood
that is the size of a actually smaller
than the size of a pinhead yeah i i i
was like holy [__]
[Music]
like i'm i'm following dudley and he's
walking all of a sudden he's like right
here because i'm falling because i don't
know what the hell i'm doing yeah you
know i'm marking you know what we find
he's like right here and i got to get up
and like basically get on my knees and
go oh yeah i see it yeah
freaking skills yeah and that's another
you know when i was talking earlier
about all the different skills that come
into play
that's just to shoot at the thing
because once you shoot at it you gotta
go find it and there's a whole nother
incredible
skill set that comes into play there
yeah and sometimes it's not even blood
sometimes it could just be fluid
like if you hit back and maybe you hit
guts
that's not gonna bleed there's not a lot
of blood in the guts so but it might
just be clear fluid
so it's not even a red drop of blood but
you're like
hey
you're looking at you know kind of doing
a little autopsy you gotta know
you're like what you smell it
dude the texture then that leads you to
blood
but yeah it's a
lot to it a freaking hard game yeah
uh you say i'm not even the best bow
shot
but i want to be there are guys in my
hometown pro shop the bow rack yeah that
are better shots than me but i do work
very hard at it the key to my success is
to throw hard work at everything i do i
can't scout elk every day so i lift run
and shoot
yeah i just like feel like that's moving
that needle in the right direction
you got a story in here that is really
just lays all this out
um
going back to the book do i deserve to
be here
i dreamt of hunting the san carlos
apache indian reservation for decades
located in southeastern arizona and
encompassing eight 1.8 million acres of
land san carlos produces what i believe
are the most amazing elk in the world
the reservation allocates only a handful
of tags each year because the densities
are low and they manage this country for
trophy bulls
this means to hunt there is very
expensive altogether a hunt like that
costs upward of 70 thousand dollars
which is more than i've made annually
for nearly all of my life
compare that to the tag from my first
out-of-state elk hunt in wyoming which
cost 1100 bucks
nobody wants to have to write a check
that big and have nothing to show for it
so there's a lot riding on me making the
perfect shot bow hunting the biggest
most coveted elk in the world adds to
this pressure you can't stop thinking
about all you've sacrificed and the
years you've worked to pay for this
opportunity to me that money essentially
could affect the quality of life
provided for my family all this stuff
starts weighing on you that was why i
kept wondering whether i deserve the
honor to be at san carlos one of the
many incredible hunting opportunities
i've been blessed with over the years i
felt like i didn't belong or didn't
really deserve the chance i'm not sure
why this is but i know this perspective
keeps me focusing on capitalizing and
being appreciative of the experience
my goal is to live up to the
expectations of being respect a
respectful bow hunter and celebrating
these special elk mountains
appropriately two words that come to
mind are the ones maximus says at the
start of the battle in gladiator
strength and honor
bow hunters need to be strong mentally
and physically but they also need to
show honor honor is to me
the attribute that makes bowhunting so
special
so
this this is
talk about like
what for someone that doesn't understand
hunting what does it mean to go into
this indian reservation where they have
limited number of elk
they're trophy elk which means they're
monsters
and they can only allow so many people
to hunt and because they can only allow
so many people to hunt and because the
elk are so monstrous
they are going to charge money for it
yeah it's a supply and demand
this place like years ago 20 years ago
there'd be a vid vhs tape out and would
say you know giant bulls of san carlos
we used to watch it at the bow rack
and these bulls seemed surreal how big
they were not even
the same species from the elk that we've
we'd hunted you know giant bowls 400
inch
of antler which is which is huge
um
so
this is like a legendary place and then
because of the money that eliminates a
lot of people pretty much everybody
pretty much everyone but the thing with
with their
um
it takes more than money because
there's a lot of guys with money a lot
of [__] with money
the
the tribe isn't going to deal with a
bunch of [__] they don't have to
because they have the biggest bulls in
the world
so
i remember this guy sent me this message
a while ago and it said he you know how
do you get to hunt san carlos i sent a
i sent an email and i guess my twenty
thousand dollars isn't enough for them
you know i'm like well i can already
tell you're probably just a dumb [__]
you know so
he could he could have
you know
offer a million that he's probably not
going to get a chance to hunt there
because they're not going to deal with
that so you have to be respectful which
i i'm always respectful but also i value
what it means to hunt there and then
also
of sacrificed a lot to be able to have
that money
and then still that wasn't enough still
it took kip
folks is
who got me the first opportunity there
and he had hunted there one year
and they could they could tell what type
of guy he was he cared he's trying to do
his his best
he didn't have the greatest hunt but he
paid his dues and and put in the time
there and then this other tag came open
and he said well i got a guy you know
cam i think you know if we could give
get him an opportunity here i think
he'll buy that tag so that's how it
happened but it takes more than just
money
it takes
a lot of things come in and kip folks
just for a little intro he's uh one of
the founders of under armour and uh
well he was a freaking college athlete
stud his damn self yeah playing lacrosse
and uh and then really was a huge part
of the driving force but behind the
operations at at under armour right and
then was the driving force between
behind the under armour hunt yep stuff
and now he's one of the driving forces
behind origin hunt fyi yeah uh he's
definitely found that's his niche i mean
he's such a hard worker and he cares
about it cares about
for whatever reason
that apparel that
just building
clothing it's like his jam he loves it
yeah
um
so you say this here kip folks one of
the original founders of under armour
and a good friend of mine was there with
me and he was the one who would give me
this opportunity at san carlos as i
headed out to the best elk country in
the world for two solid weeks if need be
i was confident
but to think i'd even get a chance at a
once in a lifetime bowl like this seemed
completely far-fetched so you're out
they identified do they they tell you
hey we got a bull here that you might be
because they're scouting bulls all the
time yeah and they find a 400 inch bull
that's their estimation
um
it's a 10 by nine yeah it was crazy
that's insane it was yeah and you
nickname or they nicknamed the the the
bull tight bull because he had like a
narrow rack with yeah ten by nine but
narrow
so
again you go through some of the details
here i'm gonna pick it up you got a
guide named chris chris and kip were
behind me over a little spine ridge
about 40 yards away all good so far the
still unseen bull screamed a bugle
and by the way right now go on to
youtube and google bull
elk bugling and crank up the volume and
then press play yeah
because it is
it's freaking primal insanity when you
hear those things going off it is
so the still unseen bull screamed a
bugle he was close i estimated where
he'd come out of the timber and looked
for shooting lanes it was a mess the
burn had burnt trees and brush
everywhere i got nervous that once he
entered the burn i wouldn't have a clear
shot i had seconds to make a decisions
at the moment of truth a bow hunter
makes certain decisions that impact
success or failure the line between the
two is razor thin
i glanced at the tree i was leaning
against and noticed some good limbs to
climb i quickly surmised that i'd
increase my potential shot opportunities
if i climbed up the tree since i had
been set up on the shady side of the
tree my movement would be much less
noticeable in the shadows scaling the
tree as quickly as i could i climbed 10
to 15 feet up in the air and set up to
shoot this elevated position opened my
shooting lanes greatly
seconds after getting set in the tree
the bull ripped the bugle answering
chris and exposing himself
it was tight bull 30 yards away
while we were in his country we had no
idea he was the bull coming in i took
one quick look at his 400 inch 10 by
nine rack recognized what bull he was
and directed my focus on getting a good
arrow in him
chris cow called the tight and tight
bull closed in heading straight toward
me and ultimately stopped directly
underneath me
i slowly eased my bow back
the bull noticed movement or sensed or
heard me probably thinking mountain lion
if you could have asked him and he
became spooked running back toward the
timber
he stopped at just under 30 yards
quartering away as i frantically tried
to get positioned to shoot while
balancing on a burnt tree limb 15 feet
up
when tight balls stood staring back at
me trying to piece together what was
happening
i had to act fast
my sight was set on 30 yards which would
work so i quickly readjusted while
trying to stay calm i settled my sight
pin on his vitals but there was one
small limb covering his chest so i
raised up on my tiptoes
in the tree and picked a spot
it was crunch time
for a bow hunter this is the most
critical moment to master as adrenaline
speeds through your body and your heart
races if you can't remain under control
success will be tough
if you can releasing a perfect arrow is
just another part of the process if you
put in the work you'll crave crunch time
because it's your chance to shine bend
that bow back anchor in pick a spot and
send a razor sharp broadhead on its way
the arrow flashes toward the ball and
lands home as you knew it would because
you've worked too hard to fail after
following a short blood trail you find
your bull and respectfully kneel by the
amazing animal that gave its life to you
the bull's memory would be celebrated
when his antlers eventually adorned your
wall and his flesh nourished you
i quickly let an arrow go toward the
biggest bull i'd ever seen
i felt confident in the shot on release
confident about the work i put in
confident the arrow would strike where
i'd visualized it would perfect
but that's not what happened the arrow
flew off the mark hitting the ball high
into the right striking the top of his
shoulder blade
a high 2 4 far forward shot is about the
worst shot you can make on a big bull
since it's high and forward of the lungs
which is where you want the arrow to hit
the bull is protected by heavy muscle
and bone so an arrow that strikes here
will typically only wound the bull and
not cause death
i felt sick to my stomach as he ran over
the ridge with what looked like half my
arrow sticking out of his shoulder
how did i blow an opportunity i'd worked
my entire adult life preparing for
my dream became a nightmare in the
fraction of a second it took my arrow to
leave my bow and hit the bowl
that was rough
that is a savage game right there yeah i
mean
so it was 30 yards away yeah just under
30.
i
feel like
if i needed to like place a bet with my
own life
and you hitting a target at 30 yards i'd
feel so comfortable with you taking that
shot yeah
i mean this is
what you do this is what you live for
yeah
and that's what makes this freaking uh
this game so crazy yeah it's so tough i
mean
being up in the tree
was a different
had some different factors in it uh
having that limb come across where you
know you don't your air the site that
you're looking at the line of sight
you're looking at your arrow is below
that
so trying to figure out where your arrow
is and that's going to cross into your
line of sight and then hit the animal
it's going to cross into your line of
sight go above your line of sight and
drop and then because i've learned that
before where i've hit tree branches that
were above my line of sight exactly so
trying to anticipate that because i
didn't know that bowl was going to come
underneath me and then spook and be
there and have that limb there i didn't
know any that was happening so having to
try to calculate all that in the heat of
the moment as a bull standing there you
know nostrils flaring eyes wide figuring
out i thought it was just going to get
jumped on by a lion
and have and i'm like here's the bull
this is a bull we've been looking for
the tight bull the 10 by nine the 400
inches is it and then you do the best
you can
and
i screwed up
it just it wasn't my best shot
and
with all those factors in there
is that did i do the best of those the
options
maybe but it
that didn't help us because the arrow
was
the arrow ended up going in breaking off
and then i had 13 inches of arrow that
had
had or broke off there's a little blood
on the shaft so
13 inches
and
you know
the last thing you want to do there when
you're getting a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity it's your first opportunity
there to hunt that country
is woundable
because on a hunt like that in any hunt
even at you know like where you've been
in utah
if you draw blood
no matter where you hit the animal
that's your animal
so
i
if i wound this bowl
and
even if it doesn't die i'm paying for it
mm-hmm 70 grand
so you and you wounded the animal yeah i
mean which is
the worst because i put
money aside i put that much pressure on
myself anyway this is what i do this is
what i've geared my whole life for so i
don't even if it was one dollar or
seven million i wouldn't have any more
pressure it's still like all this is
this is my purpose
but
the money when you're thinking about
your family and the sacrifices they've
made for this then then that just makes
it worse
and just so everybody knows
elk are not human beings obviously but
the reason i say that is because
they're so freaking tough yes like you
take you put a 13 you put a broad head
into a human being 13 inches they're
gonna die yeah like anywhere in their
torso they're gonna freaking die right
especially with i mean maybe if you get
into surgery or something
but elk
they're
crazy tough what they can survive yeah
no i mean imagine how tough you would be
if you slept outside for 365 days a year
on rock and dirt and in weather yeah
it'd be pretty pretty tough and then in
order to get a girlfriend you had to
freaking go and like ram heads yeah
fight like a bunch of other dudes that
had giant spears coming out of their
heads right right so it's like they're
they're built for that they're built to
endure
whatever
um an arrow if it's not perfect yeah
it's gonna wound them they're it's
probably gonna i don't know how they
feel pain but they're gonna they'll they
can get a long way they can go a long
way and survive a long time and they get
stabbed with
yeah
yeah they get stabbed with antlers so
this is sort of like a bad antler wound
but that's what they deal with that's
what they contain actually cleaner you
know like true broadhead is a cleaner
cut and you know you know how
a clean cut can
heal right you know so a puncture is is
one of the worst things you can get for
an injury so an antler puncturing
yeah i mean
they could overcome a point is they
could overcome an arrow wound and they
do all the time yeah yeah
going back to the book the tight bull
was a regal animal i respected greatly
but i failed to deliver the perfect shot
i [__] up the shot from less than 30
yards i climbed down the burnt tree and
slipped off my boots with just socks on
my feet and not hard sold boots i could
feel the ground better which would allow
me to sneak forward silently
and see what kind of blood
i had to track as i followed the sparse
blood trail my fears were confirmed the
bull didn't bleed much at all a few
drops which is what you'd expect given
that shitty shot
eventually the light blood trail stopped
altogether
i was devastated not only did i let
myself down and my family and friends
and followers but i felt like i let the
apache tribe down as well this bull was
so unique and so incredible and i had
made a poor shot on him he deserved
better now i had to go and tell the head
of hunting for the tribe that i had made
a poor shot
kip chris and i hiked miles back to the
truck
nobody said much
i shook my head and started stared at
the ground a pit in my stomach
it's a bad feeling dude
oh
this is like
my hands are sweating right now yeah you
know uh and
like i said i mean obviously i'm i'm
like a complete amateur in this game
but
even when i put myself into your shoes
as
uh
much of a perfectionist as you are and
as much as i know you want to
you know get the good shot and then here
you are and that's that's that's one
thing i could say about like being in
the camps that i've been in
everybody knows exactly what just
happened like everyone knows there's no
hiding
yeah it's just a
you know you want to make a good shot
you want
you want to do your job essentially and
your job is to
to be
deliver a merciful kill
of the target animal so anything other
than doing your job
is tough
especially in that circumstance um
yeah that's my first opportunity to show
you know what i was capable of in that
environment in front of that the tribe
and
yeah i didn't feel good
what a freaking rough game yeah
yeah i remember uh the first the first
time i shot a bull i had
shot a shitty shot
um
hit it in the leg luckily hit an artery
but
you know dudley and i tracked it until
dark we still didn't find it
we're walking back i mean i just
i feel absolutely like
horrible
and i feel like horrible because i
wounded this animal i feel horrible
because i let dudley down who like
invested time and effort into me
uh to to give me this opportunity to do
this
and on top of that
quite frankly i didn't even understand
that
this happened
i didn't i thought i was like the only
person that this had ever happened
and that's why when i got back to camp
yeah i sat down with you and dudley and
joe and were kind of sitting there
eating
and you must have just looked at my face
and felt like you better like help me
because
you and you basically told me like a
couple stories
and you were like hey man you know like
this happens you know
um
and it does and and you know you talk to
the guides up there and it's
you know there's a decent it's hard to
kill a an elk with one shot and it
happens instantly it's that's a tough
shot yeah
it's like one of those things though
that uh
nobody wants to talk about really but
and it does happen
and it's like
you know me and roy we'd call each other
on the phone and they'd be like
how'd the hunt go did you kill
there's only one of two answers nobody
gives a [__] about
anything else then yes or no so in a in
a hunting camp setting like that yes it
happens but like i know how the guides
talk and how just it not not there
specifically but just anywhere
and it's like how that would be summed
up would be like you know
cam wounded
nobody needs to
anything else doesn't [__] matter
did you kill no you wounded
the all the
you can justify you can explain it
doesn't matter
so it's like just summed up like no
matter how how people talk or make you
feel better or whatever
it doesn't really help
and that's why this this game is is
freaking challenging yeah and but here's
the thing that's why it's so rewarding
yeah you know and so i we i probably
sound pretty negative right now because
it's hard as hell but that's what makes
it so rewarding yeah that's what makes
it so awesome
when you pull it off and you get it done
um
so yeah
uh
going back to the book here
before going to bed that night kip and i
talked about tight bull what do you
think the odds are that we're going to
get him kip asked 20 i said
it's not good a high shoulder shot on a
big bull like that i [__] up
well [__] he muttered i had a hard time
sleeping even for a second that night
and it wasn't the first time i've had
heartbreak in the mountains
i remember more than once blowing it on
a big bowl times when i should have
gotten a kill and screwed it up and it
has haunted me crushed me
the next morning we got up and headed
out at first light to where i hit the
tight bull mark and dan stevens chris's
uncle and cousin joined us to lend a
hand if need be we all walked to a
ridgeline a mile or more away from where
i had shot the bull as i scanned across
the canyon with my optics i spotted
something that i couldn't make out what
am i looking at i asked the guys buy
those yellow quaking aspens to the
bottom left of them what am i seeing
that's your bull chris said
he was bedded i studied intently through
my binos and i didn't see him move
is he dead i asked chris cowell called
and right when he did the bull moved his
head [__]
he's not dead but he's hurt all right i
told him let me go down and get this
mess cleaned up
as they stayed there i made a big circle
around to the other side of the canyon
where tight bull was bedded it took me
over an hour maybe even two hours as i
wasn't taking any chances with the wind
and went very wide
when i was a couple hundred yards from
the three quakies which were my
landmarks i slipped off my boots and
continued on slowly and silently ingest
my socks as i neared where tight bulls
should be i looked through my binoculars
over to kip mark dan and chris and saw
them motioning with their hands with
hand signals from a mile away they were
telling me that the bull was going up
the hill when i neared the quakies i
spotted him slowly making his way up the
hill he was stoved up but i needed to
get another arrow in him or risk losing
him it was going to take a very long bow
shot to make that happen but i got a
good range on him and i knew exactly the
distance
i already had an arrow knocked so i
quickly dialed in my sight and drew back
my bow string settling my pin on his
ribs as he quartered away he would take
a couple extra steps and stop regather
himself and take another couple extra
steps i waited at full draw for him to
stop by this time i was completely
relaxed and felt rock steady
pulling my bow hard against my back wall
of my draw i cheated the pin up a couple
inches on his body as he moved
a yard or two further up the hill from
when i arranged him and slowly squeezed
the trigger of my release
the arrow arced high covering the long
distance before dropping home sinking
into his ribs as it angled toward the
bull's lungs
this time my shot was perfect i hustled
up the mountain as fast as i could in my
socks knocking an arrow as i went he
hadn't gone far from where i had hit him
and though still on his feet now his
head was down
he was he was quite a poke 92 yards but
i was in kill mode as i came to full
draw and released again the second long
bow shot
also hit him perfectly the ball went
down and after a few kicks died quickly
a wave of relief washed over me
and then you get to him
sitting beside the dead tight bull was a
bittersweet moment of relief my mind was
conflicted i had succeeded in achieving
my goal but knowing i had ended the life
of a truly majestic animal to do so
brings a hint of melancholy there was
also a solemn sense of pride that comes
with knowing once the bull hit the
ground the ending of his life would help
sustain me and my family for months
i took a moment to give reverence for
the life of the animal i killed
thanks for the nourishment beast your
flesh will fuel me and your antlers on
my wall will ensure your life is honored
as long as i live
got it done got it done and and you know
there you are the next day making
a shot at 92 yards another shot at
whatever 90 probably 94 95 yards both
perfect shots
yeah i think the first one was the first
one i think was actually 107
and then the second one i had snuck up a
little bit and he didn't go that far and
so he was 92 on the second but the first
one was a little over 100. yeah just so
everybody knows like
most people want to shoot no further
than 50 yards yeah i would say and i
think 40 is really what most people yeah
feel very confident yeah
50 is out a little bit further but 107
that's a long shot it's a long shot yeah
i just wanted to get you know i
in my head that animal had suffered all
night
and uh so i wanted to
just do what i should have done the
first time
and uh just
close the deal
it's an interesting parallel with jiu
jitsu like in jiu jitsu you go and train
and you you get tapped out by people
and you keep coming back
and like if you never got tapped out
to me if i never got tapped out i would
probably not come back as often right
if bow hunting was easy
it wouldn't be so rewarding right it
wouldn't be the draw
yeah and it's like if that to me that's
the only thing only reason i've ever
stood out in life so it's like
i feel this is what i'm supposed to be
good at
i'm this is what i'm supposed to do this
is my thing
so to fail
it like feels differently to me also
yeah i was going to say that earlier
when you were like well it's a lot of
money and there's a lot of pressure from
you know wanting to do the right thing
and i was like oh and your campaigns
yeah
you know like this is
you you carry it's like when the gracie
family does jiu jitsu right yeah they're
carrying their their family name which
is a which is kind of a rough thing
because that's hard when you're
the gracie family's huge oh man and
there might be some kid that's 14 years
old that started training two years ago
but he's part of the gracie family yeah
uh so you have you know that's your name
right
yeah
yeah so it's uh
they when they
they were watching from the ridge you
know where we first saw the bull and so
they said that me making those two shots
to kill it made up for
so that they had i had already let
everybody down and then like okay well
that got me back to zero yeah got you
leveled out together yeah did anybody
get video of it uh no
no not from that far nobody had anything
um
yeah we have never really had a camera
crew there
yeah the camera crew you were talking
about earlier like that adds another
dynamic when you're doing this stuff oh
man that must really bother you
yeah i mean i
i don't like hunting with anybody yeah
that's what i'm saying even on these
guided hunts and they theory they all
know this but i don't
i just want to do it
you know i don't need help if i screw up
i want it to be me screwing up but so
then then when you have a cameraman
there you know that there's always
somebody to blame so the cameraman is
like the worst job ever because anything
any mistake it's like
you know oh they saw the camera or they
heard you
whatever
but when it works out
like i've had camera slash blame guy
yeah exactly
i've had some hunts that i'm so thankful
we have footage for sure you know but
there's that
it's kind of rough waters there for a
while yeah until you get it done it is
pretty i mean i have some good footage
uh from last year yeah and
dudley was with me and dudley was
filming you know i'm probably the only
person in the world that gets to have
john dudley as my freaking cameraman but
he had already killed and he was like
hey
and you know he got a freaking good
video of
the you know the end of this actually
got the setup and everything units
and
i'm real happy and i will say that like
uh
like review and tape for
anything like any sport yeah you know
you can watch and be like oh yeah break
it down yeah yeah no i know i remember i
think your shot was it was it a little
back of the lungs yep like we were
wondering if it was liver it was like
one lung liver one lung and liver yeah i
remember that so that's that is good to
know because
a lot of times it happens super fast so
being able to have that footage to
review can actually help in the recovery
uh
right before that i had shot another
bull in colorado
and that one
i really would have liked to have that
on video because
i think you can help me with this so the
bowl was at 51 yards
and
i was on my knees
and he was walking you know uh from
right to left
and
quartering away a little bit i don't
know what's that called like a thing
away or something like this you know so
he's not slightly slightly quartering
and
so he's quartering away so i i thought
okay i'm gonna aim a little bit back
and then
i was waiting for him to stop he stopped
and so i you know started let it go
my arrow went and
it was like he took a step
it was this is what happened he was
looking at us
so i was waiting for him to look away
before i let the arrow go right so he
started to look away i i started pulling
back let the arrow go but he wasn't just
looking away he was taking a step yeah
so i hit him further back than i wanted
to
but
in reviewing it in my head i thought
okay so if i'm gonna be aiming at a bull
i should cheat a little bit in the
direction that he might take a step or
is that a bad call we
i wouldn't just just go with the
stationary yeah because you don't know
for sure so you don't want to cheat then
they don't take a step and then you you
know you're like overthink it almost
yeah yeah it's hard to predict what
they're going to do
and we i mean i did recover that bowl
and but you know yeah it took a while
and it took uh some expert uh tracking
to find again i was very lucky i had
dudley with me and the guide up there
helping out
um
but man they're tough oh man i mean he
went
he went
down and up
these three hills yeah that
were not fun
you know what i mean they're not fun and
he had an arrow freaking sticking in him
yeah
um
it's uh yeah
i i think almost i've seen
you know i talked about my dad or
whatever but and i'm sure you guys know
that that will to live
is pretty strong
even for humans we're not as tough as
animals but still people can really hold
on and it's like when you're that life
is leaving like it so an animal or i i
say anything i've heard i've heard even
people say oh caribou hunting is easy
they die easy and i'm like i don't know
anything that dies easy
i don't know anything so especially
something as tough as a bull elk that's
that's born and bred in the mountains
it's just like their will to live just
like anything's
anything that's alive there's a will to
live
that is just incredible yeah
and they're freaking like when you said
board in the mountains you see them
go up a hill yeah it's insane no they'll
they'll go up and over a ridge you'll
try to do the same thing it'll take you
an hour yeah and they do it in minutes
yeah it's freaking crazy to watch yeah
there
but
one thing that humans do have over
animals almost any animal other than
maybe a wolf is endurance
so
those bulls can put distance between you
and them quickly
but if you can stay on
it's it's hard finding country that that
would
allow this but that's like in africa
that's what they do they stay on these
animals and then they get the animals
get exhausted before the humans do so we
we have
you know endurance is that's our pretty
much our only advantage yeah and i would
caveat that by saying some humans
yeah
maybe not everybody maybe not the woke
ones
uh you gotta
some crazy stories in here uh here's a
story
with roy in it roy stared in the face in
danger in the face of danger and didn't
blink this happened during brown bear
hunt we had gone on earlier in july that
year we'd had a big snow a big sow brown
bear that turned into a problem she saw
us from about 130 yards away and started
running full speed right at us roy
readied his three his dot three five
seven
gonna get some
that he'd brought as backup
and i knocked an arrow
not sure what an arrow would do to a
charging brown bear but that's all i had
does that say three five seven or three
seven it says three seven five oh three
seven five no that's right yeah yeah now
357 i was like well that would be a
pistol i was like i hope that is a
three five seven three seven three three
four seventy five yeah that's a magnum
that's what he had that's a brown bear
gun
he's uh
roy said if she gets to our side of the
creek i'm gonna have to shoot her she
crossed the creek without hesitation and
ran toward us at about 20 yards she
stopped and stood up aggressively
huffing and staring us down
head rocking side to side
[Music]
we were standing in the wide open in
knee-high grass so there was no
mistaking we were humans we were giving
her a chance to make a better decision
since we didn't want to kill her unless
we absolutely had to get out of here we
hollered it didn't matter the brown bear
dropped down
and with deadly intentions and ears
pinned back
she charged roy fired one shot and
stoned her at close range
mere feet from us
i couldn't help uttering a loud and
inappropriate cuss word [__]
i was mad that we had to kill another
beer bear
i had killed a nice boar already and we
were on a high after that awesome
success and sweet footage of my perfect
bow shot now we had killed now we had
had another killed which we didn't want
despite the fact that we were in grave
danger that aspect never even entered
our minds after i cussed mad shaking my
head roy said matter of fact dude i had
to
i replied i know it just sucks a typical
response might have been oh my god we
could have been killed are you okay i'm
shaking
but i knew i had a partner but i knew
the partner i had in roy he shared the
same type of confidence i had he was
never rattled and always in control i
knew in 10 lifetimes i'd never find
another partner like roy
good times yeah that was that was a
bummer uh
she had these uh full grown cubs with
her so they'll stick around sometimes
they don't need to be with the sow but
they hang around for a while before they
split off
so she had those with her and i don't
know what it was but she i
shot this boar
and she had heard something i think
maybe when the arrow hit him he made a
noise and because she had her those
full-grown cubs and it was a bore boards
will kill cubs
and so she heard that noise didn't know
what so she came over and then smelled
blood from
my bear
tracked that blood all the way out to
where he died and started tearing him up
she was he she was attacking him and
hair and stuff was going everywhere and
i'm like i go dude she's tearing up my
bear
and so we're yelling at her and i go i
said shoot out there not not to shoot
her but just shoot out their spooker so
he shoots nothing
and uh she didn't pay attention
then she turned and looked and she saw
us and we're about 130 yards away and
she just came
just sprinting
and it's like a bear a br big brown
bearing like sprinting through the grass
at you it's just like oh god
you're knocking up an arrow yeah i'm
like i don't know what i'll do but
and so we didn't want to kill her at all
and it was just like the biggest downer
and even when i was in this video i
think it's still on youtube but i'm
sitting there with the with the
bore i killed and roy's in the
background he's like looking because
those full-grown cubs they're still 400
pounds they're not really cubs they're
they're yearlings
but uh they're they're back and forth
and he's looking at him he's just
shaking his head because it was just you
know they obviously were going to
survive
they were old enough to survive but it
was just
a downer we're not trying to kill a sow
you know
and uh
we ended up calling fish and game
on the satellite phone saying what
happened and which happens a lot up
there that's it's called defensive life
and property you can kill bear if your
life's at risk
and we had to skin it out and take it
back in and do the paperwork and do all
that so we did all that but it's not
that it was you know legal or anything
like that it was all it was all legal
but it's just
we just didn't want to have to kill
another bear but
um yeah we were in those situations
quite often which happens you know they
they say we have a greater chance of who
knows what getting struck by lightning
than being attacked by grizzly
not if you're hunting grizzly all the
time if you're hunting grizzly all the
time it's like 75 chance you're going to
get attacked
so we were used to it but it's still
you know it's pretty intense yeah the
the bears
they're
kind their bears are psycho
is that is that is that a accurate
statement
yeah grizzlies have a different although
that's a brown bear which is a you know
a grizzly two but
so i would i killed another bear up
there there's a limit there's so many
brown bears and non-resident can kill
two
but we had this bait set up which was
legal this year that that we were
hunting is 2015
and the the
black bear would come in and they would
just be pretty docile not
wound up at all pretty relaxed
then a brown like the big boar that i
killed the brown bear not not that one
described there but a different one it
would come in and it'd just be rocking
back and forth just like
kind of like possessed and it looked
like a dinosaur because
it was nine foot six tall you know it's
just a but on all fours so it looked
really tall
and rocking and just like scanning all
around you're just like oh my god this
thing is insane yeah they seem like
psychos yeah yeah they and they killed
their babies
yeah and they're freaking huge
and so strong
all right
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
i was in colorado bow hunting with kip
folks and mark womack
i spotted and stalked a big colorado
whitetail i hustled toward the buck as
quietly as possible he saw something a
few times but i was staying pretty low
crawling mostly we figured he thought
it was another buck so while i closed in
on him he started coming my way
he came pretty fast licking his lips and
even stopped to make a scrap in the
sagebrush at 60 yards he started to
skirt me a bit so i figured it was time
the shot felt good but it was a touch
low
and he was quartered too a tiny bit i
felt it was good enough to kill him so
mark and i backed out planning to come
back at first light to recover him
that night before before bed we reviewed
the footage and concluded dead buck
looked like the liver but you never know
i climbed into my bed that night with
excitement and belief that we would find
the buck in the morning
sleep wouldn't come however
at 11 pm my cell phone rang it was trace
roy's been in an accident she told me
she didn't know all the details about
what had happened so i knew i needed to
call jill roy's wife
i phoned her and asked what was going on
after a long pause jill said
cam
roy's not coming home
jill's voice sounded soft and tired i
asked what do you mean
she said
he fell
he passed away
my stomach dropped and the darkness of
the old farmhouse kitchen i stood in
there in the middle of nowhere colorado
felt darker and lonely
i couldn't believe her words
right away i thought of their children
taylor and justin and ellen
roy had fallen 700 feet from a cliff in
the nasty country we hunted sheep in
he was on pioneer peak the exact same
mountain where i had killed my ram in
2008 and where roy had killed rams since
now in 2015
the mountain had won
in this uh this chapter the book is
called legends never die
mm-hmm
yeah i have a hard time even thinking
about this still without
getting
choked up um
i just
you know
there's people that
that come into your life that uh
i don't know he's just one of those guys
who always believed in me and we had
you know it's like a bun you go through
hard things with people and i know it's
i can imagine it's like this with the
military where you have it's like a
brotherhood you know because of what
you've went through
and so that's how it was with
with uh roy and i and that in that
regard
um
so yeah
i don't know we had a lot of big plans a
lot of things were going good for us
that we talked about and dreamed about
for our whole lives you know he's
becoming an outfitter up there
he's
like a legend up there people would talk
about roy and alaska it's hard to be
legend a legend in alaska there's a lot
of
a lot of legendary people
but he was earning that name and uh
so yeah felt
i don't know still feels
i mean i'm still
upset about it still mad
because
you know we had so much left to do
yeah i know a lot of times you'll you'll
post pictures of them and whatnot and uh
you know it reminds me you know you're
talking about the military aspect of
things and
i mean i still post pictures of my
friends that i've lost and
i can tell by what you write that
he still is pushing you even though he's
not here and you know you can go a
little bit further
and you can be a little bit more roy
tough as as you put some of those things
and that's
the same thing i think about you know
the same thing
hey i mean i got guys that died
when they were way too young way too
young yeah and
they don't have the opportunity to
carry on and the opportunity that to do
the things that i get to do right now
and even if that thing is just getting
up in the morning and going for a
workout
like that's a gift you know
well i would i wouldn't
roy started me with bow hunting i mean i
wouldn't be here it's like
normally after i would do something like
this i would call
roy and we you know this is this is all
part of our thing or
we did it
and uh
you know that's that's a reason why i
mean i picked that picture on the cover
of the book that's from our last hunt
and uh it was a moose hunt
two weeks before he died and uh
you know
i mean it's just
you gotta get by you gotta you know if
you wanna
they say it might be cliche but you know
people die twice
when they when their life ends and then
the last time somebody mentions their
name
and so
just like you bring up the guys that you
know that that you've lost
um
i'm always gonna honor roy i'm doing it
right now this is what i'm doing i'm
doing it in the book
um because without him i wouldn't be
here and uh
so
i mean i
yeah it's just
it's tough i mean i still
jill i'm still in contact with jill all
the time and
um
yeah just
i don't know life-changing yeah
um and again i
do you put so many cool stories and
details about all that that it's another
reason just to to get the book and and
learn some of those things and keep
saying that name
um i want to close out
you know obviously i'm not reading the
whole book but i just wanted to close
out with one one uh section here
um towards the end of the book you say
many years ago i decided i was going to
work hard every day on being the very
best bow hunter i could be
along with taking care of my family that
is my purpose in life everything i do is
prioritized around this drive and this
dream i start at 5am and finish at 8pm
every day i give it my best i have
gratitude for the gifts and
opportunities i am given i enjoy the
journey
steve prefontaine was right to give
anything less than your best is to
sacrifice the gift that's exactly how i
look at it bow hunting can be a struggle
it's hard and very competitive it can be
very cut throat
but so can life
life can be tough and beat us down we
experience loss a loved one or a family
member or a job or a dream
we battle our own demons and
dependencies we all take hits and get
beaten down
that's when we have choices to make
only you can choose not to hesitate only
you can keep moving only you can climb
over snow and ice and tough footing and
steep rugged country
what dream do you hold
that you're not going to let go of
if i can do it anyone can
but you will have to earn it
you will have to endure
you will have to keep hammering
um
so
again
if you're listening to this get the book
uh
let's make this thing a freaking best
seller
just to spite the people that don't want
this book to be a bestseller
uh
so many things and like i said there's a
bunch of things i didn't cover in here
and
as you've said about the book is and it
clearly isn't it's not just about bow
hunting
it's not just about bow hunting at all
it's about life and it's going to do a
ton of things to help people
uh
get through whatever they're getting
through and be on the right path in
their lives some of the things we didn't
cover in this book i just wanted to keep
hammering mm-hmm
so you
according to the book you do talk about
this but uh bob fromm who's uh a san
diego kind of legend uh archery guy
hunter he runs performance archery here
in san diego and he used to call you cam
the hammer is that where that originated
from yeah you know you know bob yeah
yeah you know how he's
charismatic and always just talking he's
like kind of cool
so he'd say you know call me and say hey
what's up cam the hammer
so
just him
i he was kind of a legend to me too you
know he was on a magazine called western
bow hunter and he seemed like he's on
the cover all the time and so uh
he made bow hunting cool surfer yeah i
was gonna say longer hair
kind of good looking guy he's like
pretty badass
and then you got a section in there
rogan talking about rogan
how did you how did you meet rogan
originally
i don't know he sent out a tweet
so i went and did his podcast in 2014
and then i took him a bow
and if you know him it's like once he
gets into something it's all the way
right watch out so then i said well
let's go let's do a hunt and a good
first hunt is a bear hunt because it's
usually close and i could i could uh you
know
be there with them and i don't know if i
agree with that bro yeah well it's just
the the shot distance isn't
less can go wrong it's adrenaline
yeah i don't know there's really one
major thing that can go wrong
well that's yeah that's with the
tracking and the wounding and all that
but if you do things right it can be
pretty high percentage of chance of
success so i thought let's go on a on a
bear hunt and uh it's funny he killed a
bear we got a picture of it and i
remember we were up there and i'm like
i go hey uh i put up a posted a picture
of you and your
and your bear and he's like yeah i know
i've heard heard all about it already
because it's like
bear and then if you're like a celebrity
type and then killing a bear it's like i
thought people think they're endangered
you know because you know people think
they're winnie the pooh yeah
or endangered or both and so yeah he was
kind of you know that's where he really
was the point was driven home about
hunting and animals and
there's a negative connotation with it
obviously people who don't do it or
don't understand it
anyway so that was in 2014. yeah and you
uh that's another part of the book that
we didn't really talk about i mean you
explain all that stuff you explain
how hunting works and how conservation
works and how
animal management works and if you just
let these animals
go like there's some species that'll get
completely wiped out and that'll off
balance everything so
all the stuff is so tightly controlled
yeah um that it's actually what keeps
the environment in balance
well i saw this very popular he's like
kind of an animal rights activist he's
got millions of followers he posted this
video of this
leopard attacking a man in kind of like
a city right
and he said he go see this is what
happens when
humans encroach on animals animal uh
like habitat that's what he said and i'm
like well no [__] that's what
that's what we do everywhere that's why
animal numbers need to be managed
because that's that's what cities are
there used to be animals here now
there's a city yeah so as the city grows
we're encroaching so you can't have the
same amount of animals that were here
you know 20 years ago if there's less
habitat so that's where that whole
balance and the biology and the carrying
capacity of land come in
but yeah it's and hunting funds all that
that's the key point with there's kind
of a catch phrase hunting is
conservation well it's just because
hunting pays for that habitat
enhancement and the studies and the
welfare of animals yeah and joe wrote
the forward to this book which is
awesome uh
did a great job with that and
you know
like uh
i guess people sometimes i guess they
might get jealous of joe rogan
because he's got so much uh
popularity
but man he's good at [__] like you would
just say like he's freaking good at
archery yeah
he's good people like you know what do
you really know about fighting dude that
guy fought that guy's a black belt in
jiu-jitsu i know and then they think
that
doing a podcast is easy oh man
and doing the way he does a podcast is
easy talking to people off the top of
his head for two three four five hours
like
crazy no i listen to a lot of shitty
podcasts
that those people think podcasting is
easy
but joe does make it seem
he does it's so it's so hard to make a
conversation interesting
and
you know the first time i went on there
i'm like so do you have a like got
questions or he's like no
no he's like
he's oh we're just gonna i'm just gonna
[__] most of the time if guys just
sit down just to [__] it's going to
be awful yeah yeah yeah
and people think that other people want
to hear you [__] yeah well if i want
to do that just go to a restaurant and
sit in the booth next to you and listen
you talk about freaking what you're
gonna get grocery shopping today right
because
or usually it's about some kid's t-ball
coach who timmy should be playing more
starting but
it's just whatever how long was it
between when you
got him a bow and he
went hunting for a bear
i think i mean a few months probably
right yeah i can't remember when i went
down there but we went spring bear
hunting so it was about this time of
year
in 2014 i believe
yeah i can't remember but a few months
you know he was confident in shooting
you know because he probably did it 20
hours a day because he's pretty
obsessive
and now uh we're actually kind of
unified now in a way cause we got
you
joe
kip
me pete roberts with this
new uh venture origin hunt yeah making
american-made hunting gear clothing
uh
that's a
kind of
big step for you going into founding a
company and
moving in that direction
how's that feel
feels incredible i still feel like the
the small town guy making 4.72 cents an
hour working part-time at a warehouse
and now you say founding a company it's
just
again this is all all this journey and
the whole point of all this i think in
the book and everything else in my story
is that
just
staying staying on the path
staying on the path and over time
who knows what's gonna happen you
couldn't have told me back when i was a
kid getting drunk and punched at parties
because i got a i'm a smart ass
that do you know someday you're gonna be
doing this i'd be like
you've got to be talking about somebody
else because there's no way so it seems
surreal
but
you know you make these relationships
and these decisions and you keep working
and working and working
and after 30 some years like this how
this journey has been who knows what's
gonna happen
and i i was thinking about this
yesterday as i ran on the beach i saw
this kid down there
um fishing
you know and i'm like what if this kid
like i couldn't imagine if i lived here
would i what would i do how would i have
stood out in anything i don't know but
mate i was wondering what if that kid
he's down here fishing by himself
and you know made the decision to come
down on a saturday morning and hey let's
see what i can do what if that's going
to lead him maybe he's going to be the
most well-known
fisherman in the world at some point
but you can't tell from a glimpse into
you know when you're when you're young
you don't know what your life's going to
hold you don't know you know then you
have kids and you want them to be
special in their own right and this all
this journey that's all the book is
about it's just like
you know stay true to yourself keep
working hard endure and
who knows
next thing you know you'll have your own
uh line of hunting gear how exciting is
that
i mean you see the you see the how fired
up people are oh yeah yeah i mean it's
amazing excited about it because i've
been saying and as i've said every time
i talk about this there's no more
patriotic group of people
than hunters
and hunters don't want to buy stuff
that's not made in america yeah and they
don't really have many options right now
and they're about to have options i mean
i think if anybody could be half as
excited as kip is that'd be a pretty
damn good start
he's like going through he's always you
know loves the videos of trying this
stuff on and bending over and talking
about the cuts and it's just like
and this guy has i don't know how much
money a lot of money yeah from when
under armor went public
and
he doesn't have to do this so it's like
you know it's just passion and it's it's
what he
loves
and so
how could you not be excited for that
and
yeah and he doesn't have to do this and
originally he reached out to pete
just because he saw what we were doing
with origin he saw that we were just
making freaking
geese jiu jitsu guys in america and
thought that was cool yeah and probably
probably also thought man i better help
these jackasses
out because he's
i mean he
has grown up doing that yeah literally
from college on and i mean when he
rattles off kind of the stats of like
you know i open 38 factory you know like
it's i forget what the numbers are but
yeah it's an incredible i mean think
about how big of a company under armor
is right and
he was he was running that on the back
side um for all those years and built it
so he's definitely been a huge help to
pete uh
pete roberts is the other owner who
he's like the manufacturer from our team
you know and he's done an incredible job
of build something from the ground up as
well and so this uh
we so we kind of had the ingredients
well let me rephrase that we had some of
the ingredients right we had
we had pete who knew how to make stuff
in america right that's part of the
ingredients
um we knew i could get the word out
about it
uh kip has
the the actual experience to get it done
and the design experience but you know
we needed somebody that was
legit that actually could say this is
what we need this is how it needs to
work and
who else you know why not just
why not just throw a freaking uh
a 200-yard archery shot out and see if
we get a bullseye we've pulled it off
well it's i mean it's an honor to be
involved for sure because it's it gives
me so much pride just to knowing we're
doing something that
could make a difference you know it's
like that's that's our whole point of
life is are you what are you doing
that's gonna make a positive difference
and um i feel like this is you know it's
causing a ripple effect and
you know bringing those videos it's like
it's like i saw one the other day origen
put up and i think it was is it dax yep
and talking about you know he feels like
he's just a small part of the machine
but but
talking about bringing american
manufacturer manufacturing back to
america
it's it reminds me i watch this old
series called the men who built america
have you watched it i have watched a few
of those right so it reminds me of that
it's like that that type of effort and
that vision
it starts there yeah and it's it's when
i see those factories in the working and
the workers and the people and the pride
in it and the and i
like peop like people like dax it's like
i don't know it
gives you butterflies almost
it's special yeah it's it really is and
it's um
to pete's credit
pete got told this was impossible
five years ago you can't there's no way
we can manufacture geese in america he
got told that like everyone kind of kind
of looked at him like he was kind of
crazy
and maybe they were right yeah maybe
pete is a little bit crazy yeah but
you know just like you did with archery
he just
kept
at it and kept trying to figure out
oh how do you overcome this obstacle
what do you do in this situation how do
we get by that
and
he he built a great foundation and has
great knowledge and then you throw
someone like kip into the mix who's done
all that and taking it to the next level
uh because you know pete's a humble guy
he's not sitting around thinking he has
all the answers and so when you throw
someone like kipp into the mix who does
have
he might not have all the answers but
he's got a lot of them
you know from from the business side
from the manufacturing side from the
design side he's got like a incredible
amount of experience so that's awesome
and then having you to give your
guidance
which is really what everything's based
on it's like what does this guy
one of the premier
bow hunters in the world
what does this guy think this should be
like
then let then we have then we have
something special yeah it's well don't
you think that that like you mentioned
pete and being humble don't you think
that that's a key ingredient to like
businesses like this is ego i see
ego killing so many great opportunities
so the fact that he's humble and like
and says he doesn't
he probably has a lot of the answers but
just being open to hearing somebody else
it's so paramount to a successful
business i ego kills so much that could
have been special yeah yeah i mean uh
obviously i have a leadership consulting
company and
when people people always ask what's you
know what's the main problem that you
see and it is the main problem that we
see is ego
you know i don't want to listen to your
plan because i think my plan's better
than yours
and i don't even want to hear your plan
because i think my plan's better than
yours that's just all ego yeah and and
to just be able to say hey you know what
cam i think let's try your idea that
sounds like it actually sounds like it's
better than mine let's go with that to
have that open-mindedness is what brings
on
it is what brings on success
i mean it's just like anything else
but you know if you're doing jiu-jitsu
and you're like hey i already i know how
to do an unlock i guarantee you get on
the mat with
dean lister or jeff glover
they're gonna be like they're gonna be
able to teach you something about that
arm lock that you did not know this is a
move i've done a thousand times i've
done it ten thousand times maybe even a
hundred thousand times but if dean or
jeff or someone that's an expert goes
hey you should move your hips a little
bit more over here you should hold the
wrists like this you're going to learn
every time
with with bow hunting you you go oh
how do you think we should do this what
can i well even more important
you know when's the last time you said
you know what
i'll be good
my shots will hit i shoot enough i don't
need to shoot today that's a lack of
humility yeah never that never happened
um but i think it's i do want to say i
mean having you say those nice things
about me is like seems surreal to me
um i think the key part is like you say
you have this a consulting business but
you actually
you you live it it's not like you're
just a lot i know a lot of people who
teach who don't follow that same
principle right so
i think that because origin has been set
up it with this
approach about maybe your idea is better
maybe i need to listen to this maybe you
know whatever just being collaborative
and it's i mean this is what happens
this is the kind of excitement that's
generated in the and the potential
that's there with the right attitude and
the key pieces in place but you know you
see it i see the key pieces in place and
they don't work they don't work because
that
there's whatever i guess ego or there's
who knows what yeah
the term i use you have to be able to
subordinate your ego which means you
actually have to be able to say you know
what
pete
you will go with that
that let's go with that i'm i'm good and
not be like well actually i want to do
it my way yeah
and here's the thing if my way is better
then i should be able to articulate that
right in a way that you go
yeah you know what that actually makes
sense yep that yeah i can't argue with
that cool let's go forward and that's
what you need to do
ideas shouldn't be driven by ego they
should be driven by what's the best idea
right that's how you make things work
and that's how we're going to make the
best freaking hunting gear in the world
and we're going to make it right here in
america
and we're going to bring back jobs and
we're going to teach people skills
that's what's that's what's amazing is
you we are we have a whole group of
people that now have a legitimate skill
and they have a career
some of the people that work for us
they
they already knew this this skill but
now they're able to use it again because
a lot of the factories went overseas now
they're able to use again some some of
these younger folks
they're learning it right now i mean we
got a kid that know that knows how to
make you know how to weave material
it was a lost art and he grabbed it from
from uh the last guy that really knew
how to do it who lenny who actually died
but
that skill's been captured now and now
you got somebody that's gonna has a
freaking awesome skill and contributing
to the world and contributing to the
economy and contributing to the
community and contributing to america
like what how awesome is that yeah it's
incredible
all right um
your family
just real quick i just want to give
props to your wife
credit i feel like
sometimes my wife you know my wife
my wife married me when or met me when i
was an e4 in the navy
um
i always tell her she married me for my
money
i think i was making like twenty two
thousand dollars a year or something
like that when she met me yeah no prenup
no freedom yeah she she didn't want half
of that
she would be better off for getting
obviously so props to her and then uh
true it i met your son true it a few
times
um seems like a stud yeah i know i know
he broke uh
goggins pull-up record he did yeah has
goggins come back on that yet he hasn't
no
that's a tough one because i i it even
took goggins three times to get it yeah
you know so it's like your body
you might want to do it your doesn't
mean your body's gonna hold up yeah
that's a tough one with those little you
know your your grip and your forearms
small muscles and your and your hands
just getting trashed yeah
people ask that about steel training
like it's all mental and i'm like well
not really
because no matter how bad you want to be
able to do that rope climbing i always
use rope climb because rope climb
yeah rope climb is
there's no gutting through a rope climb
right like you can gut through
you can you can gut through much more of
a rucksack march
like part of that okay you can have you
can you can have like a heat stroke and
fall out yeah
but a lot of that is just like gut
through it yeah you can gut through
boats on your head right like you put
the boats on your head during hell week
that's just a gut check there's no if
you if you are a
19 year old american male
you can you can withstand and you can
perform the physical activity of boats
on your head running around
uh
but a rope climb yeah your mind will not
get you to the top of that freaking rope
only your body will so you you're out
there like oh it's a mental game yeah
yeah cool climb that rope then i really
want to climb that rope yeah but if you
can't do it
all the mental strength in the world
isn't going to get you up that rope all
right and then uh and then true got
lucky that his body cooperated that day
that one day he chose so it was like
yeah anyway but he did it yeah
what is it 4200 4100 4100 yeah goggins
had done 4032.
yeah
but he was supportive the whole oh yeah
he was he was good he
you know he he met true so he was he's
good with it it's always whenever you
see somebody pushing harder you know
like that people say in jiu jitsu look
i'm going to get you one day to me i'm
like i hope so yeah and jiu-jitsu works
yeah if you work hard
that's what happens get rewarded yeah
i'm not going to be mad at someone
because they freaking i'm actually going
to be stoked yeah i'm going to go train
harder train more that's the way it
works and then your other son
is
in the army yes a ranger
rangers lead did they make the
connection
while like he was going through did they
figure out who he was that you were his
dad or was some of them he wanted to be
like low pro yeah just like
clinton
don't stand out for any reason don't get
any extra attention
don't nobody needs to know when your
birthday is obviously that's like the
worst thing in the military it seems
like is if people know your birthday
so yeah
and then you got one more daughter in
high school yeah she's graduating this
year she's a senior right on awesome uh
echo yes you've got any questions or
yeah i do actually how much does it are
you ready to be a bowhunter
yeah i am oh yeah actually would you
mind let me ask you wait did i did i go
too hard in the paint on bow hunting as
hard
because it's hard no no okay but it's
challenging but it's rewarding did that
it seems accurate from my position which
is very limited by the way as we all
know
so that reminds me of a quick question
so you know how like
let's say a guy that i know has a
crossbow
are bow hunters and crossbows or
crossbow guys kind of at odds a little
bit crossbow isn't bow hunting
so yes then
so if i said hypothetically
that i have a crossbow
would you be kind of mad at me would you
be like would i be like one notch lower
yes
okay i understand that was the hype okay
and how much does an arrow weigh or is
it do they vary your weight yeah my
arrow weighs 540 grains okay so there's
grill okay yeah just like a bullet yeah
yeah yeah and then the tips you can you
know what yeah
yeah those can be from 100 grains or
even smaller to uh up to 200 grains and
then you have what like the different
like broadhead arrow yeah what is that
like the three the blades right there
like blades yeah so that's a broadhead
yeah and then what other kind do you use
or
is that even a thing well there's
there's a field tip that you practice
with so it has no blades
and then there's an expandable broadhead
which means that flies with the blades
uh sucked in and then when it hits
something the blades come out they
expand out to cut a bigger hole and then
there's a fixed blade broadhead which is
what i shoot where the the blades are
just out the whole time um and is that
like what just the typical ones or is
there like a vat you know how like in
bullets yeah there's all kinds you can
get all kinds of broadheads a lot of
people are a lot of
normally
people don't use expandables for elk
some people do
and they work
i've
for one reason in oregon fixed blade
broadheads were the only thing that were
legal until like a year or two ago so
that's all i've ever used
and
expandables can cause problems if they
hit heavy bone like that tight bull
story with expandable i wouldn't got
that ball
the the my arrow wouldn't have went in
13 inches i wouldn't have been able to
get another air on it the next day so i
would have lost that bull with an
expandable
[Music]
and expandables also
can hit if you hit like a maybe like a
twig which is already like you you
already got problems if you hit a twig
or something but it can open those
things up maybe early and now yeah like
you can have more problems too yeah
but the expandable
kind of big hole can open a big hole
like big
so two so just
field tip expandable and then rod fixed
blade so is there like exotic okay so
let's say i know what you're saying he
wants to know if there's like uh the
twists
designer broadheads or what or whatever
rambo do you remember that's what i was
gonna say like you got the explosive
you know all these other ones or
whatever like is it like that with
arrows or what you know there hasn't
been an explosive i've done some uh
there has to be excuse me no i did i do
there's a guy richard ryan and he used
to he might have been an original
investor or i don't i can't remember
anyway he was part of black rifle for a
while
and he we did some trick filming with
with uh archery and bow shots and
different things like i shot i i shot
cheese off a mousetrap that he was
holding
okay so we're trying to see if i can get
the cheese off of it before the mouse
trap got my arrow
so he held it and i shot it but another
one he did was we put propane flame that
shot up and then a paint can behind it
so the arrow would go through the
propane flame
pull the flame and then puncture the
paint can then it would explode
and it's like a huge explosion so i made
a joke that was like i was shooting a
rambo broadhead
but there hasn't been a rambo broadhead
yet like in i think it's rambo too
one of the greatest films of all time
yes sir yes
but there has been one where they're
shooting is like a 357 shell casing or
shell on the end of an arrow and it
would like i think they killed some hogs
with it like it hit the hog and then
fire the primer yeah
huh i've never used one but
that's the closest we got to rambo i
could see where
since i know echo pretty well i can see
he's got all kinds like he wants to have
a a selection of the party designer yeah
uh broadheads different ones yeah
so there's no twisty one you know like i
figured that would be a thing
the broadheads i use
actually the blades come off at an angle
and i think it enhances because when an
arrow flies for it to be accurate there
has to be helical on it
just like rifling on a barrel
so that's what gives that direction
just like a so a muzzle loader if it's
just a ball isn't very accurate but that
twist so same thing with the narrow same
principle the fletch on the back of the
arrow is what gives direction to that
arrow well my broadheads come off at an
angle and i think it enhances so when it
hits an animal it's twisting as it cuts
and i think it cuts a
more devastating wound channel because
it's going like that so it cuts a hole
instead of just slices yeah
you gonna get some things for your
all crossbow yeah i'm gonna look deeper
into this stuff yeah all right right
right on i like it uh cam any closing
thoughts anything we missed uh like i
said i it's an honor to be here i mean
i've i don't feel worthy of sitting with
you guys
honestly
um
this is
i never thought i'd be here i never
thought i'd be here talking to you you
guys are larger than life for me and for
a lot of others
we actually had this training at work uh
not long ago and the trainer mentioned
uh this navy seal jocko
and he's like and i was just like god
dang i know jocko
so yeah this seems you know i used
surreal earlier but it does it feels
i don't know i'm just i'm honored to be
here i'm honored that you looked at my
book
and you actually gave me advice when i
was selecting a publisher that's right
um because you use the same publisher as
me same publisher saint martin's and uh
so you gave me some great advice there
and you've been a resource and now we're
partners and it's uh
it doesn't feel like my life but thank
you
well right old man i as i mentioned
earlier i feel the same way like here i
am talking with the freaking world world
class dude and and it's just awesome um
so
thanks for coming on thanks for sharing
your lessons learned
and and thanks for your encouragement
to
me and so many other people like there's
so many other people i i know that you
inspire so many people
um
to get on the path of bow hunting but
not just get on the path of bow hunting
just to get on a better path in their
life and i think this book is going to
do that even more
and uh as you said uh it's an honor to
be working with you partnered with you
and to to take you know this thing is
you know talk to kip talk to pete to i
can feel it there's like a rocket it's
like a rocket you can watch the for the
fuse it's burning right now september's
coming we're testing product
like we're ready to watch this thing
go richter
so thanks for what you do and thanks for
uh inspiring people all over the world
thank you to keep hammering
thank you guys i appreciate it right on
and with that
cameron haynes has left the building
echo charles
are you ready to become a bowhunter i
think so yeah not a crossbow hunter no
no no so yeah so the
i was trying to think of
crossbow hunting versus bow hunting and
i was trying to think of what a good
example would be
um i kind of landed on surfing versus
bodyboarding maybe that makes sense to
me
no disrespect to
bodyboarding
but
something along those lines a little bit
where
let's face it let's face it it takes
more skill to surf
than bodyboard fundamentally
sure but no again no disrespect to the
sponges at the highest level yeah out
there getting after it
that the fact is i don't know
but it seems that
that that's the case yeah so even like
um yeah okay so i know a guy with a
crossbow you know and he let me shoot it
from time to time and
i have shot a bow beep
bow before when did you shoot a bow well
actually the last time i did was about a
week ago where at greg train's house oh
that's right greg train's on that yeah
his was little like his arm's a little
shorter than mine so it's like it wasn't
but then i shot one at the origin camp
one of the guys i had one yeah okay and
i dig it i'm with it man
i made a bullseye do by the way but it's
neither here nor there okay not just
naturally skilled like that so then
why'd you buy a crossbow
the guy you know has had the crossbow
from before either way yes the bow
seemed or has a lot more going on for
sure
so i can dig how you'd say that it's not
i was going to think a ghee versus nogi
but it's not that because nogi they're
both both highly respect yes
respected
and difficult and uh there's a lot to
both of them regardless of perception
okay i found it i think i found it right
skateboarding
versus scooters
scooters like two wheels
so that's what your crossbow is you're
on a razor scooter taking up room in the
half pipe yeah
yeah that's what's going on did i make
and i asked you this during the podcast
but
it's so hard bow hunting is so hard
i hope i didn't discourage anyone from
trying it and doing it
but you got to recognize there's a lot
going on man this is not an easy game to
play oh yeah that's freaking hard oh
it's real hard actually and you know
like even that that opening that you
opened with like it made me physically
feel
probably
a good element of how hard it is because
i remember back you know like when i'm
thinking okay the first time i ever shot
a bow i'm like okay this is like dude i
gotta pay attention to all this stuff
and then i gotta aim in a certain way
and i like all this stuff and then
that's just my there's probably not to
mention like the 1000 things that i
don't know about
and then you want to mix that with
actually going out and doing it with any
animal any animal it's it's it's crazy
and then you gotta learn about all these
different animals because they all act
different by the way like a bear does
this and uh elk does that and uh
deer does something else like they all
have different reactions they all
different senses so
and then you gotta like i said that once
you shoot that animal then you gotta go
find that thing if you got a shot that
was good enough to make the animal bleed
so the thing is yes extremely
challenging other side of that spectrum
it's an awesome reward awesome reward
you asked do i want to be a bowhunter
now mm-hmm kinda
bro
and here's the thing like i think and
this is a natural and this it didn't
start right now though i think right
right when cameron haynes even
john dudley when they kind of came
exploded onto the scene yeah bro i felt
it then
kind of dope
and you know you see other people doing
it and them talk about it kind of just
kind of um exposes it
in a way that you know i haven't been
exposed to and i'm sure a lot of other
people the same same deal because i
noticed a lot of people picked it up
after that kind of started yeah for sure
yeah
i feel it i feel it so yeah i do kind of
all right well good hey uh you're gonna
need to get in good shape yeah if you're
going to do any kind of hunting or if
you're going to do any kind of living by
the way just being alive i recommend you
be in good shape just like it pays to be
in good shape when you're out on the
mountain maybe you could get that
one-tenth of a percent that's going to
make the difference what's that one
tenth of a percent in life
let's think about that so that means
staying physically active healthy
working out pushing yourself you know
what that means
yes what does it mean well it means a
lot of things but you know
so i with my kids and you guys kind of
mentioned this before right well with
kids like they're watching you
know
so sometimes they're going to be like oh
i see you know dad's doing this so they
might want to try to imitate a little
bit just to see what what the hype's all
about you know
and so my kids in my very specific
situation like they'll start jumping in
on the workouts or whatever start making
little goals and stuff like that and
they have to
endure
things like doms or they're
doms that's basically what it is right
but when you're a kid dom's is like you
don't know what that is you just think
it's like just your body's breaking down
you're like i'm six years old i got doms
what up no not yet until you explain it
or whatever but either way you get
soreness it's not all like
freaking bull's eyes is what i'm saying
true
you know you get some pain
you get some aches and some good days
and bad days is what i'm saying it takes
effort
well when you start feeling some of
those bad days maybe you need some more
protein
right get yourself some mole
get yourself some joint warfare get
yourself some super krill get yourself
some chocolate fuel jackalful.com
make that happen out of the gate
we got
new flavors
on the energy drinks yeah that are
coming all the flavors are new right so
again you mentioned that before we
started recording and it's uh the way
you said okay to clarify they're not new
flavors they're the same flavors
redefined or re-mastered remastered yeah
and even you could just say mastered
because
here's the thing the initial flavor
profiles let's call them
they were based on my
sense of taste which my sense of taste
you know not eat a bunch of sweets all
of a sudden i drink something with monk
fruit in it i'm like whoa you know i'm
used to drinking water
that's it right
so you put a little monk fruit in
something and i think i'm i think i'm
having a freaking
uh a dang
coca-cola
right sure with a with a little tiny one
tenth to one percent of some monk fruit
in there i think i got a coca-cola i'm
like yeah this tastes delicious this is
so sweet
i was wrong yeah
so
we've adjusted
so that they taste even better
kind of hitting the shelves right now
depending on where you're at depending
on yeah depending on where you're at but
as you're hearing this it's time to
start getting back into the game um if
you didn't like the original flavors
we made them all they taste here's the
thing we're going to win on taste now
before we were winning on
this is good for you everything else is
poison it's actually going to kill you
yeah you we were winning on that yeah
and and winning on that but you also got
to win on taste so now we're going to
win on taste we're moving on on all
fronts yeah
so there you go yep dockerfuel.com i
will come in your way second that being
someone who has tasted the new flavor i
will agree with that wait flavor or
flavors because i've tasted all the new
flavors and they're all well i just
tasted the mango so oh no no the mango
and the orange so yeah yes they're
freaking delicious yeah uh you can get
the drinks at wawa you can get all the
stuff at vitamin shop or you can get it
all at jockofield.com check some of that
out
and
if you watch the video version of this
on our youtube channel
jacquelinepodcast you're probably going
to see cam haynes you're going what's
cam haynes look like and they're going
to go whoa what's he wearing on his
upper torso
sure
you heard us talk about origin hunt
so origin hunt is coming if you want to
check into that or if you want to check
in whatever american-made just pair of
jeans you want to check american-made
pair of boots you want to check
american-made t-shirt american-made
beanie america made wallet belt whatever
if you want to bring manufacturing back
to america you want to support america
you want to support freedom if you're
anti-slave labor
go to origin usa.com
get yourself what you need yeah don't
get tricked do you you can be
anti-uniquely priced labor
what's that same deal what's this
uniquely priced labor is that what they
call it like a euphemism for slave labor
yeah yeah are you serious yeah that's
the the what do you call the the
euphemism the buzzword yeah the one that
sounds good yeah that's euphemism yeah
yeah yeah this sounds good yep that's
exactly what it's unique what's called
labor yeah yeah they in fact is a
freaking kid working for a dollar a week
oh yeah in cancer-causing conditions
forced to yeah by the way forced to so
this is america
yeah this is america
we're not we're not doing that
we got american made stuff
support it
originusa.com this is america you know
like saying that
you kind of sounded like pete right
there when you said it like that does
pizza like that yes
oh i haven't heard him say that yeah not
to mention jiu jitsu stuff as well on
there yeah you know american made
because
oh yeah yeah we were doing you know what
it would call spring cleaning you know
i was observing but
it was going on at my house and you know
i
my wife brought out all the geese that i
have to kind of organize or whatever
and yeah i saw the comparison you know
you still have the
uh geese apparently i didn't know but
are they in the garbage now
in the garage on the floor
we were heading to the garbage yeah yeah
exactly i'm so happy i don't have any
other keys anymore yeah it's kind of
worthless you know you know no offense
but they're kind of worthless kind of
kind of it show it shows you how
malleable the human mind is yeah because
we all just thought that's just how it's
going to be just a just wearing the most
uncomfortable thing on your body
while you're trying to be athletic and
move around no reason for that no reason
for no reason for that originusa.com
it's true
also if you want to represent while
we're on this path it's hard it's a hard
path
as one might say um but hey you want to
represent go to jackalstore.com where
you can get your apparel other apparel
this one equals freedom we've got some
new discipline equals freedom standard
issue by the way what back to old school
i don't go into too much detail but it's
a basic design discipline equals freedom
and there's certain layers on there
that you'll probably notice we'll say
if you have a keen eye you'll notice the
layers nonetheless we got some new stuff
on there anyway if you want to represent
that's where you can get it chocolate
store there's also the shirt locker
which is your subscription
shirts short every month
good design
unique unique creative fun in fact this
last one i'm not going to tell you what
it is maybe i will but
it was one of the you know every once in
a while you'll get one where people will
actually go out of their way to send you
messages with them wearing the shirt and
say hey you knocked it out of the park
with this one
i got that this past month or this
current month
wait have i seen it yet nope oh so it's
not released yet this is no it's
released so now everything's live so the
first of the month you i don't care if
you sign up on the first month or you
your order is on the first one it it's
that much it's all current so yeah it's
this month what is it may yeah that
makes sure we're just gonna be very high
uh esteemed
either way um yeah jocklestore.com yeah
and if you can subscribe to the shirt
locker and you can subscribe to the
podcast
allegedly
go go out there leave a review or
whatever they say to do
oh yeah uh jackonground.com we're doing
a lot of q a on that we're also
addressing some of life's
some of the aspects of life that we can
gain an edge on that maybe we weren't
thinking about yeah right so
that's probably a good thing to pay
attention to the reason we have that is
there's strange things going on in the
world there's censorship people are
getting banned shadow banned the whole
nine yards we don't have any control
over the platform that you're listening
to this on right now but we do have
control over jocko underground.com so if
you want to help us out there you can
sign up for that it costs eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month
if you can't afford that we still want
you in the game
you can email assistance at jocko
underground.com we have a youtube
channel
you can see
what cameron haynes's awesome looking
sweatshirt he took it off after a while
because it is warm yes yeah so about
halfway through we had to take a little
break
and uh
he had to he had to take her down
yeah you don't want to let the aesthetic
value
uh diminish
because of the functional value you see
i'm saying
if it's not cold or if you're not
enduring the elements you might not need
that so i'm gonna put that on the side
so there you go uh youtube channel check
that out psychological warfare
i think i said we were gonna make
another one of those like three four or
five years ago at some point in history
yeah get that done flips on canvas.com
dakota meyer making cool stuff got a
bunch of books say hey the book to to to
invest in right now endure by cameron
haynes
ford written by joe rogan
freaking great book
lots of knowledge in there like i said
it's not just about it's not just about
bow hunting bow hunting is the vehicle
for lessons to be learned
so check that out only cry for the
living
by holly mckay
there's a book we covered it on this
podcast
you might want to check into that book a
raw account of war that holly
who is a badass
risked
life and limb to go and capture stories
on the ground in war so check that out
final spin
leadership strategy and tactics you go
all the books i've written if you want
them go get them ashland front
just got back from uh battlefield out of
gettysburg
powerful
next up in august is little bighorn
we're gonna go do the lessons learn walk
the battlefield at little bighorn
so if you want to check that out we have
a muster coming up
in denver
anyways if you want to come to an
echelon front event go to some front dot
com check out the events there also if
you need help in your organization
we can give you leadership help that's
what we do also the academy online look
you know you got to go to the gym
if you want to stay in shape i do yeah
leadership's the same way you don't just
you just go go to the gym one time now
you're good
yeah not to mention
actually it might be kind of the same
thing but not to mention where
so i've been in this game for a while
being around you
for a while and there's stuff like
within the last one month actually more
than one thing by the way
that hit me in a different way to make
me realize it
and it's stuff you've been
saying in one way or another for the
whole time years yeah by the way and
then you'll say it a certain way or
you'll interact with someone a certain
way and be like oh that's what he meant
oh that's how you know so you'll come
across things that'll be revelations
over time yeah
extremeownership.com
is about life
it's about how to do better in life in a
bunch of different ways so if you want
to by the way if you've got a question
you want to ask me just go on there i'll
be live
on a zoom call
and you can ask me whatever you want
we'll work through it and if you want to
help service members
active and retired
if you want to do good
you want to provide some medical
treatments
for
for service members
go to america's mightywarriors.org
also check out heroes and horses.org
i've been making the mistake of calling
it comments.org.org
i was texting with micah the other day
and he's like
you know he's kind of like
he's kind of like he goes hey
appreciate the support.org
so sorry micah
sorry about that and hey don't forget
you can find
cameron haynes he's on instagram he's
at cameron haynes
and he puts up a lot of awesome stuff
puts up a lot of awesome stuff
he does a lot of stories
so if you want to check that out give
him a look as far as echo and i go we're
both on twitter i've been on twitter
like i've been you know back in the game
on twitter it seems like it's moving in
the right direction a little bit more it
was kind of getting a little sketchy for
a while
so i've been hammering on twitter a
little bit
echo's there i'm there we're also on
instagram we're also on facebook echo's
adequate charles i'm at jacqueline but
once again
watch out
the algorithm
the free dopamine hits you're getting
the dopamine without suffering suffering
it's bad for you
watch out for it don't let it hit you
and
uh thanks once again cam haynes for
coming on
so many lessons to learn
and
[Music]
we appreciate it and it's an honor to be
working with you now at origin hunt and
of course thanks to military personnel
active duty and veterans
that protect our way of life around the
world we are forever indebted to you and
also thanks to our
police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service all the
first responders you make incredible
sacrifices to keep us safe here at home
and we are grateful for what you do
every day
and
to everyone else dispersed throughout
cam's book are a bunch of
short sections and i didn't cover
i don't think i even covered uh
very i've covered a couple of them today
might actually no i don't think i
covered any of them but they're these
short little sections that provide some
insight into cam's mindset that i think
will be helpful
to anybody that's trying to get their
mind right
here's one of those little sections
it goes like this you make a good shot
this season
nobody cares work harder
you miss this season nobody cares work
harder you got a promotion at work
nobody cares
work harder your dog died
nobody cares work harder you won the
super bowl nobody cares work harder
really cares about your goals
nobody cares about your excuses for not
achieving recent success
yesterday means nothing
recent failure
give all you have today
what you've accomplished in the past
means nothing
we don't rest on laurels it is time
to work
and with that until next time
zecko and jocko
out